[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
the premier online speed Jazz tournament
a knockout filled with tension drama
quick tactics and shocking moments
oh my gosh for the last seven years and
counting the best Blitz and bullet
players in the world have flocked to
chess.com to prove their worth at this
format
excitement rains every year with major
upsets and intense battles
year 12 invitees and four qualifiers
face off for the title dozens have tried
but only two have ever worn this Crown
Magnus makes it look easy
wins the speed test Championship spits
in a row who will be this year's Blitz
King it's time to find out
[Music]
welcome to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship
presented by coinbase
[Music]
welcome back everyone to the 2023 speed
Chess Championship presented by coinbase
we are excited to welcome coinbase as
the presenting partner of the speed
Chess Championship yesterday we saw some
exciting action today we promise up
another excellent match in store for you
all I am Grandmaster Robert Hess
alongside me is Grandmaster Benjamin
buck and Benjamin yesterday Wesley so
made his way to the semifinals today we
go back to the round of 16 to watch
yonda palmchi and our generation
hello everyone hello Robert great to be
here and yeah Robert like I said
yesterday was an absolute Thriller
between alireza and Wesley so but today
we have another very exciting matchup we
have janapamyachi against Arjun Eric
Garcia Robert I think John has to be the
slight favorite in this one but it's
gonna be close I think origen is a very
tough opponent
and Arjun he's always hungry he's placed
so much chess these days Jan well he's
happy just to be in the field he was a
last second replacement for ding Lee Ren
and as we look at the bracket we know
one semi-finalist that was Wesley so
taking down all there is a farooza
yesterday and oddly enough we have one
match that has not been played in the
first round the winner of which plays
Magnus Carlson
exactly yeah so you will see nepo the
seventh seed against Arjun the 10 seed
so by the Numbers we can already
conclude that this is going to be close
one and uh yeah I think that's what
we're gonna see for sure and even if
they make it through they're gonna play
Magnus so uh they definitely did not
have an easy bracket
well Jana Pomchi he knows playing Magnus
Carlson and matches like and well he
didn't know what it was like to be in
the SEC in 2023 until just about this
week because he replaced dingley Ren at
the last moment and he was a little
bitter one could say his tweet said I'm
simply not good enough he shrugs that
and Benjamin he is good enough he's
always welcome at top events do you
think he'll be able to uh you know be
happy to be here this time around
you know I mean I'm I'm sure he's happy
to be around I mean the SCC is the
Marquee event here on Chelsea com and
he's part of it
but um yeah we'll see if he can make it
through origin again I think he has to
be the favorite but it's it's for sure
not going to be easy
yeah I think Jan was a bit quiet at
least in the online sphere until he won
a Champions chess tour division two the
latest one and he won title Tuesday this
past week bedroom I'm sorry to bring up
unhappy memories I know we get along
very well so please forgive me but Jana
palmchi just a couple days ago he took
down none other than you in the final
round to win first in title Tuesday
and thank you for reminding me of Robert
I was leading title Tuesday I had my
opportunity to win the event the first
time in my career but John and in my run
we see that he had a very tough run he
he played Duda he played Lavon olikoff
but yeah he won his first title Tuesday
in 17 months so Robert and that just
goes to show what a tough fuel title
Tuesday has become
it's the best of the best the cream of
the crop always join the title Tuesdays
or two of them each week don't miss it
if you're a title player out there or if
you're not just have fun watching it but
somebody who has been in many events on
chess.com server is Arjun eragisi so
while he may not be quite as experienced
as Jana palmchi is an important title
under his belt he won the 2022 jscc the
junior speed test championship and
Benjamin that was an impressive set of
opponents
yeah look at his run he beat them as Las
Vegas he beat Mohammed muradli he beat
Hans demon and in the final Robert he
beat nihal sarin nihal always goes super
deep in the speechless Championship so
that again goes to show what a too good
player originar guys he is
[Music]
because they say oh this this J in front
it's the junior speed Chess Championship
but let's think about recent winners we
have gukesh in 2023 we had Arjun in 2022
with nihal in the two years before that
so bedroom I think at this point you
could just remove the Jade all of those
winners they belong in the SEC
yeah and I'm sure I think it's very
deserving that the winner of The JCC
gets a spot in the SEC as we see with
nihal he he has proven that he uh he is
among the best on the website so uh yeah
for sure these players deserve their
their spot and um we'll see how Arjun
will fare today against Young
it's going to be a tough battle for sure
but let's dive into the numbers let's
get a little bit more specific with this
because we're thrilled to have Deloitte
a leader in their field as the official
Data Insights partner for the speed
Chess Championship their dedication to
Excellence Alliance perfectly with the
chess.com mission to grow the game in
support of Chess so let's dive in to our
Deloitte game analytics and Benjamin
3320 those are the ages but what do you
make of the chess numbers there
right so we see the nepo leads in their
head ahead with a 25 to 12 score they've
had seven draws they've never played in
bullet though and Robert I think that is
going to be a big factor I I think Young
doesn't play a whole lot of bull perhaps
origin has the edge there he does play
all bullet and this is their first time
meeting in the SCC
and it's going to be fun for both of
these players and I think these ratings
are of September 4th we just mentioned
that Jan won the title Tuesday a couple
days ago his rating is even higher than
that and there you see yonda palmchi
that looks like a man who is ready for a
long match uh he is in our Focus here he
just joined the tournament but he's
looking fresh Benjamin
yeah it looks like he just got a got a
haircut or something he's looking uh
ready to fight so um yeah I'm curious to
see what we can expect from him
well let's look at the second page of
our Deloitte game analytics because uh
these numbers I think they're quite
important we see that yonda palmchi he
has the peak Blitz rating lead over
Arjun in recent times and Arjun has the
bullet edge over Yan so when you look at
these numbers including the total amount
of SEC games who would you give the nod
to
yeah I'd give the slight Edge to John I
think he's definitely the favorite in
the blitz portions in five plus one and
three plus one but we see Arjun he has
the highest higher Peak bullet rating so
there is potential for origin 4 for a
combat in the blue portion
for sure we know that Arjun he's the
speed demon when he needs to be so if
it's a close match watch out for the
bullet just like we saw a day ago but
let's dive into the smarter chess
predictions I typically have some
disagreements with smart chess although
he's been quite accurate this time
around Benjamin you look at this the
lead in Blitz for yawn by one point in
the five plus one two in the three plus
one and an even prediction in bullet
what do you make of these numbers
yeah I think they pretty accurately
reflect from what we can expect in this
matchup I think Young is definitely the
favorite in the five plus one in the
three plus one portions I'm slightly
surprised that they think it's it's even
chances in the one percent portion but
we see that overall it gives yon a 66
win probability and origin at 34 win
probability so from that we can conclude
that if they play three matches Jana's
gonna win two and Arjun is going to win
one
right and this could be the one for
Arjun Eric icy chat please get involved
let us know what your prediction is I
know some of you filled out brackets
with dingly red instead of Yonder
palmchi now's your chance to get
involved in the chat vote do you think
it'll be yawn do you think it'll be
Arjun Benjamin I think it's up for grabs
as you mentioned two out of every three
matches according to Smart chest should
be won by yada bombshi but there's only
one today
exactly yeah and also I had a very quick
look at Young's profile he very rarely
ever plays uh plays bullets and origin
yeah again he plays a lot so I think
it's definitely going to come down to
this uh that portion right there and I'm
very curious to see Robert what kind of
openings both players will will play I
mean Arjun very often he just jumps
around from one opening to another what
do you expect
well Argent has very deep preparation
and young has played two World
Championship matches so he must have
some of the best preparation after
winning consecutive candidates
tournaments and as we see Jan here I
feel like he will jump around I think
he'll play his risky style of Chess he
does not mind going for adventurous
positions and we'll see if he trusts his
instincts against Arjun in those
scrambles that's I think the key to this
match
yeah I know for sure I don't know how
experienced both players are in the
scrambles I again I would think that
origen is perhaps slightly more
experienced because he plays a lot of
Buddha that being said I don't seem that
often in title Tuesdays and like I said
Jan recently won the title Tuesday so
perhaps there he has a slight Edge
that would make a lot of sense Arjun
he's competitive he's playing a lot over
the board he plays that online but we
haven't heard his name at the top of
title Tuesday which really is such a
huge accomplishment that Jana Palm she
was able to take earlier this week and
so Arjun he's not playing from his usual
setup I think he's on the road right now
and he better have trusty internet
connection because we have seen that
plague competitors in the past
right and do you have any idea where he
could be I mean is there any tournament
currently going on where he might be
traveling to or maybe a training camp
something like that they had the
training camp before the Tata steel a
chess India event they actually had it
at the hotel where all the players were
staying at so they had training with
Boris gelfand you know that Arjun is
sharp he did quite well in the blitz
portion of the rapid and Blitz so for
our generic icy he's definitely informed
I'm not sure he might be playing in the
Spanish league or something like that
we'll try to figure out where he is but
young the Palm should he's looking right
at home in that chair
you know I mean I can speak from
personal experience it's always an
advantage to play from home you're more
you're more comfortable with your mouse
you're your chair all that stuff so that
that should give yon even a slightly
bigger Edge
and we see the players they're getting
set to start their first game of the
match I'm curious as well Benjamin we've
seen some players they have the zoom
call open so they can see their
opponents it's not like playing over the
board we can see all those emotions but
Wesley for example he is often looking
at the zoom call to see how his
opponent's reacting
right yeah it's uh it's really a
personal preference and by the as we
speak we are off and we have a nimsa
Indian with E3 and that of three D5 by
origin but yeah I used to keep the zoom
call open but I feel like a lot of
opponents don't give anything away at
all so these days I just closed it in
and focus more on the games
now okay well that makes a lot of sense
why don't we do that here and this looks
like a position that yonda palmchi is
going to be excited about in this match
isolated Queen Pawn on D4 uh but in
exchange for the iqp you get play in the
adjacent file so Benjamin as we see the
opening moves of the match we see Jan
playing with really great speed
yeah let's see John going for the
Rubenstein variation against the Nim's
Indian now here black has a decision to
make you can develop your knight to
either D7 or C6 but this is going to
allow the D5 push from White and there
we have it by Jan so let's see what
origin is going to do here I think the
main line continues with Bishop C3
pontics E6 then it goes something at
some point you take an e F3 and after
some long forcing line you reach an end
game where white has a slight Edge but
often it ends in HR but I forgot exactly
how the line goes but that's definitely
it it's Bishop takes Knight Pawn takes
E6 Bishop takes other Knight and Arjun
either he's unfamiliar with the exact
moves in this position or he's trying to
remember his line because Bishop takes
C3 if you didn't know that it works out
it looks like it could just lose on the
spot because the pawn takes E6
exactly yeah but if you don't go for
perfect C3 and you go for Pawn takes D5
white is considered to have a slight
Edge after Knight takes D5 and why does
some activity in the center uh whereas
Black's piece are slightly clumsy the
997 as you target the bishop B4 can
often be hanging so I'm surprised Robert
that Arjun is spending his his time here
and he does not played the move Bishop
takes C3 and if you wanted to avoid all
of this there's also the move H6 instead
of Knight bd72 to avoid the D5 push
right he actually brought his Knight in
front of the queen and Rooks usually
wins showdowns against the queen on an
open line so if he takes on D5 I'm
worried for him because after the series
of exchanges there are all sorts of
threats for white to win a piece because
the bishop on B4 is loose the 97 is
pinned and yeah I'm just checking I'm
making sure that origin is still
connected it seems he is and wow if his
E5 so he doesn't actually take this Pawn
on D5
right and now we see nepo pausing E5
yeah it's not a move that I am familiar
with and we see the evil bars slowly
creeping up it's white should have have
an advantage here the question is how do
you prove it though do you go for Knight
takes E5 well then there might be a move
like rookie 8 putting the the knight in
a pin there's a four but then there's
all sorts of Bishop C5 checks or maybe
just Bishop D6 attacking the Knight on
E5 so so Jan has a lot of a lot of
options here and that is why he has
stopped to think
precisely zero chance I would take on E5
if my opponent spends all that time
before pushing up to E5 at some point
I'm saying Arjun I trust you let me work
around that pawn but I actually don't
really know what to do for white I'm
always tempted to play D6 uh Mike coach
always said it's the 20 rule that one in
every five times it's going to be good
to push that pawn but you should always
consider it to the sixth rank instead he
develops his Bishop to G5 Benjamin I
can't blame him for that but now we're
seeing a transformation of Pawn
structure who do you think this favors
yeah very interesting position we see
that white has the two Bishops also D
pass Pawn on D5 however the policy three
is someone who the opponent D5 could be
weak uh that being said opponent E5 is a
Target so I feel like nepo should have
the advantage the bishoper currently is
looking pretty strong Rook C1 Pretty
Natural move to defend the spawn of C3
that being said though perhaps white has
to act quickly if you're doing it
quickly and black is able to establish
some sort of blockade with let's say
queen if you're going to line on D6 you
move your rook in then I think black
also has the potential to to get better
but for now white certainly has a slide
initiative
some clear long-term weaknesses for
white but as you're saying that if white
acts fast you can make use of the fact
that you have a pass Pawn on D5 and
Arjun he slides his Queen up to C7
directly attacking his Bishop on C4 and
if the bishop drops back to D3 maybe we
have E5 to E4 with a fork and then a pin
on the e-file
yeah that's definitely a worth
consideration you can also just play
Bishop B3 to keep defending the pawn on
D5 or maybe bishop B5 to put some
pressure on this Knight on D7 Jan just
goes for Bishop to B3 and Robert what's
always so annoying about playing
janapomishi is that he always plays
Super quickly and look at the clock he
is already up one minute on the clock so
let's see if he can put that to work
well he put his C Pawn that was a
weakness to work to defend that pollen
D5 that frees up his Bishop but that
Bishop on B3 it looks like just a pawn
over there I think in the near future it
will reroute to C2 or to A4 uh
particularly A4 because the E5 Pawn will
be tender at some moment I like this
position for white I just think that the
queen on D6 is not the best block hating
piece we'd love to put a knight there
instead
very quickly by nepo and altitude origin
is going to do the position is not that
easy for him to play because he would
love to go Knight C5 and rookie the
problem is if you go 95 right away you
hang up on E5 and if you go rookie eight
then there's Bridge Bay four your knight
of Spin and you can no longer go go
Knight C5 so let's see what he's gonna
do and we see yon expanding his
advantage on the clock
and look at that by the way Knight to H5
the bishop left control of the F4 Square
so the Knight hops out to H5 suddenly
arjun's feeling like he may have an
initiative and if White's not careful in
comes F5 in comes G5 that Bishop on H4
it might run out of real estate
yeah for sure so let's see what jono's
gonna do I mean Bishop G3 feels like a
bit of a Pity now black and just
straight so another trade excellent move
by by Arjun and yeah move like G3 isn't
very appealing as then you completely
block out your Bishop maybe some of like
92 attacking the Knight and enabling the
move Knight E4
yeah that Knight reroute to E4 looks
strong but the Black Knight gets into F4
first he goes for your line I think that
black immediately has to play Knight F4
he
does that and is there any sort of
attack against G2 that's what black of
course wants for example Queen G6 you
can't play Queen G3 because then there's
a fork on E2 but that's a little bit too
obvious he would have blocked with his
Bishop instead of his Queen and so
that's why Arjun gallops the Knight out
to C5
right and Bishop C2 instantly by nepo I
don't think he he might not have been
that worried about Arjun trading the
knife or the bishop but maybe he was
worried about a 93 drama now we see F5
by origin perhaps at some point and nepo
is gonna play Bishop G3 attack the
Knight of the four they're being said or
in case black Tom's back to G6 F4
becomes a serious threat so I I feel
like I feel like John should still have
the advantage here but it's it's looking
very tricky that line that you just
pointed out that if you played Bishop G3
Knight just hops back to G6 that looks
great for black I actually don't really
see how white easily saves the piece
there so that Bishop H4 move when he
played it and I like F3 it actually
opens up the diagonal for that bishop
and it was given an exclamation point I
think it deserves it it's a great move
it frees the bishop up but Benjamin I
think earlier when black played H6 it's
now clear That Jag chose the wrong
Square for his Bishop retreat
yeah perhaps he had to go to a different
scorers Bishop but it's always a
trade-off with uh with Yom he plays
Super quickly he puts pressure on his
opponent but sometimes that does mean
that he makes inaccuracies but here look
at the clock forward he's up a minute
origin already only has has one left
it's it's looking problematic and here
we see rookie one attacking upon E5 the
evil part is not seem to like that move
and it looks like such a natural move
you're just going after the black center
what could be the problem here Rook E8
played with Eva bar goes right back up
so maybe there was one opportunity there
one shot not to take some Eminem songs
into the show this early but perhaps
black needs to play B5 at some moment to
shatter White's Pawn structure
yeah I wonder what the idea or plan is
that we are are all missing but rookie
is very natural move by origin defending
Pawn on E5 of course you cannot move the
afro because then you hang the pawn on
F5 so now let's see how in how Yawn is
going to increase the pressure but I
think it's more difficult for Arjun to
just make logical improving moves and
that's why he goes for a G5 a very
double-edged sword he pushed the bishop
away but this also weakens his King on
G8
that's for sure the case and whoa H5
Connect Four on the fifth rank but
Benjamin where's the attack that you're
throwing your pawns forward you're
exposing your own King
yeah exactly an H4 nice move here by
John in case you go G4 upon the control
of white can seriously consider Bishop
604 followed by giving up their Queen
for the turoks and I think that should
what Knight G6 Queen X G5 that's a big
Pawn to throw
uh that's not just one Pawn F5 and H5
are both loose that looks like two pawns
are falling so actually Bishop takes E5
now might even win a Central Pawn
Knight F1 also nice move by John he
wants to go to E3 and again look at
arjun's clock he's got seven seconds
left queen of six was played but this is
looking like it's it's going to be nepo
right Queen takes H5 the queen can
always slide back to G5 after that you
steal a second Pawn in front of the
black king young he's well ahead on time
Benjamin this is what we expect from him
yeah for sure and I think that's why
he's also the bigger favorite in the
blitz portions he is just better at
managing his clock he's just plays Super
quickly and I can tell you from personal
experience it's it's pretty annoying to
play him
yeah because he plays quickly and well
it's that deadly combination and there's
a rook on h8 now is there any potential
for an attack down the h-line tonight
for black is coming to E5 that's an
amazing block Candy piece and then I can
slide into G4 and suddenly the white
king is not perfectly safe
I see Arjun trading on a three followed
by Rook H3 wait all of a sudden it might
get a little bit tricky but can't you
just go King G2 and meet Rook H shade
with Rook H1 in case of Rook G3 you just
go King over it still feels like it
still still feels like Jan should be in
complete control here
adios Rook H5 step in the wrong
direction because now he only is one
Rook activated for black you need both
of them there if you swap Brooks off on
G1 that should be good enough for weon
but he's taking a think and that's very
smart Benjamin because King F6 King E5
King D4 at some point could have been
scary whoa well and look at that move E5
great time by yawn in case you would
have taken with the e-rook I guess it
would have been Rook H7 he takes for the
girok for that reason so there is rookie
to the end but now maybe you check over
here he goes for H7 so where exactly is
the win
no
drawing opportunity
there's some chance to double your Rooks
on the second rank but it's not quick
enough oh that's a brilliant move
I like the the professional approach
here by Young he just trades off one
pair of Rooks now the game is completely
over and he wins his game I thought for
whatever reason that black had a fork
but the bishop is a beetle there's no
Fork at all
yeah no this uh was not accessible to
arjun's pieces and now we see Jan with
the black pieces go to his trusty Petrov
we saw this line in previous matches I
like it a lot because F2 is hanging and
it gets very exciting
yeah for sure so I wonder if this was
this world championship preparation for
Magnus he takes upon an F2 Bishop takes
F7 this gets super Sharp King G6 I
believe is the move here and now you are
down a rook with white but the Knight on
H1 is trapped and the kingdom G6 is
super weak but I guess
I think Jan uh perhaps he just knows it
all
and this was played yesterday between
Wesley and alireza all the rest of the
white pieces and he actually obtained a
big advantage in that game at some point
it was really messy that white knight
went up to D5 and somehow won the Black
Rook on A8 it was a forcing sequence but
look at Jan he doesn't look bothered he
goes D5 but that's a mistake
yeah apparently he said I saw the movie
what happens actually in case white
takes the pawn Knight takes D5 looks
pretty tempting a fun line here Robert
is that King H7 runs into Knight F6
check and if you think there's queen of
seven Checkmate so what do you even do I
mean Bishop B6 and out of four looks
problematic well what does he have in
mind in case y takes him there we go
and he goes Knight C6 with the eval bar
goes all the way up this is the problem
or maybe the good thing Benjamin is that
Jan doesn't know he's made a mistake we
see it the engine is screaming for a win
for white what happens after Knight H4
check to bring that Knight in and then
Queen E4 coming if the King goes to our
Knight of six check actually Force mate
you pointed it out before
yeah and that actually looks like a
great movement what do you do I mean
King F7 runs into this discovery that
looks deadly after perhaps Knight xc7
out of where exactly is the Checkmate
after King E7 I don't see it right away
but but Knight H4 looks like a nice move
I mean do you have to go to H5 that
looks super scary there's got to be a
Checkmate there for white
yeah that that can't be good oh but
Arjun plays Bishop E3 still keeping the
advantage and why don't we bring up an
analysis board here this is a good
position to look at a little bit more
deeply because Knight H4 check instead
of Bishop to E3 that looked like a very
forcing variation and maybe you're right
maybe the king had to go up to H5
because this show you're lying with kh7
first maybe that's a good for the
viewers to recognize the Tactical
variation you mentioned that if the king
had gone back Knight F6 check is deadly
exactly another six and the king is
stuck on H7 so that is very very nice
variation so I don't know I don't know
what black had to do here I mean giving
up the queen it literally is not going
to be good enough the bedroom look what
happened in the game look what happened
and John's laughing if you refresh the
board here
oh my God you ran right into it Knight
F6 and he can resign and Robert this
must be so frustrating for Jan he won a
great game with white pieces but within
a minute or so he's already thrown it
away
yeah we didn't even have to analyze it
apparently because Jan let it happen
he's laughing because he can't believe
he just missed this and he walked right
into a checkmating attack he has to
either give up his Queen in which case
he's completely lost or just resign
because he's getting mated
exactly because King G6 Knight H4 is
Checkmate the king is stuck over here
the all of the squares are covered so
yeah I think he just has to has to
resign or well perhaps he can give his
Queen you do have a rook in the night
but your knight at each one is going to
get trapped in the next couple of moves
so let's perhaps have a very quick look
Robert at what he should have done
instead of D5 and there we have the
resignation apparently the move is King
H7 here right away
wow so he'll have to learn that during
the break if he wants to repeat this
line because it's way too risky to play
like this in Blitz chess if you don't
know all of the ins and outs and we saw
Arjun he steals his first Victory it's
one to one and for Jan you just have to
forget about that and better let me ask
you something as a chess player you know
as a strong Grandmaster when you lose a
game like that do you feel like they're
easier to forget about because you're
like okay I'll just look at my prep
later
it's it's tough it's tough because you
just you just throw away a point right
that's pretty much what happened he did
not lose because Arjuna played him or
whatever I mean of course the opening is
part of the game but again in the first
game he he crashed he he played he had
played origin pretty nicely right but in
this game he he just threw away a point
so that must be pretty upsetting and the
question is whether he is going to be a
little bit tilted from that loss
and Magnus said that between these two
players Jan is the more tiltable of the
two uh but let's see how he rebounds in
game three here this promises to be an
exciting opening uh we see that white
has regained the pawn but black has
these passers on the queen side in your
experience do you prefer this from the
Black or White side
yeah it's it's an interesting I've never
had this actually with either white or
black this is actually called the no to
Bone variation I know probably most
people will refer to this as a nude boom
but we see indeed that like as these
Queen side Passover it's white in his
big Center and after the move Queen into
Robert Kim blight just had the pawn some
motion right away with the move A4
that looks extremely scary to my eyes I
guess the one idea that black needs to
be very careful about is if after A4
white plays D5 with Bishop takes F6 to
follow because you need to make sure
that your king side isn't getting
shattered this is exactly what's
happening so Benjamin Ken black just
played Knight B8 to D7 that feels like
the safest option
yeah that looks like a nice move for
origin just defending the Knight on F6
also you can potentially get some
control over the C5 square and I like
his position I mean black is a very easy
plan just A3 to follow B3 potential as
well and I don't really see yet what
white is going to do in the center
taking E6 no big deal you just recapture
with the f-pawn and I mean E4 can always
be blocked with move E5
and that dark Square control is really
nice for black guys especially for E4 E5
and those Queen side pawns they're very
fast and the A3 comes with the tempo if
you protect the a300 then B3 happens
that Knight on D7 can jump up to C5 I
think that origen it should be very
happy with his position from the black
side here because I actually don't see
an easy plan for white you might have to
stop those past pawns immediately with
Rook F to B1 and get defensive
yeah no for sure this opening has gone
much better than the one from game one
and this is pretty impressive Robert as
some players they will stick with an
opening even though it's not working and
also because in a match you just play
one game after another there's no time
to search anything up so if an opening
is not going your way very often it's
just better to switch it up and play a
different one
and Knight D4 gets a question mark can
black just play A3 that would be my
first instinct to force the bishop back
to C1 but sometimes the problem with
pushing pawns too quickly is that you
give up squares and you're not able to
push that second Pawn so at least by
having A4 and B4 it's kind of like
hanging Pawns in a way that you have
your choice upon pushes
exactly I think I think Jan wants to me
to move a through with the movement
Knight B5 attacking the queen in the
case taking B2 you can take on A8 first
so that should still be fine but perhaps
black just moves the Queen the question
is where though because if you go to B6
there's going to be Bishop D4 so so
let's see what Arjun is going to do he
can also take the pawn on D5 why why not
oh that's it's so funny I'm just looking
at those past pawns but e takes D5 does
look like a free Pawn Knight F5 ideas
come to mind for white and Arjun says I
am not afraid of that normally it's a
knife on F5 we like to call it but this
doesn't look much like a knife looks
like a plastic one that you get on the
airplane so you can't even cut your food
right and here we have to move rookies
who won by uh by yanya 95 doesn't seem
to do a whole lot
now I guess he wants to meet A3 with
Bishop A1 keeping the bishop on the long
diagonal makes a lot of sense so let's
see what Arjun is gonna do here one
thing I want to point out Robert is that
the clock Advantage is not significant
yet but Jan has already sped up here and
that could certainly be a factor if
origen drops one time again
he recognizes his positions in danger so
he's gonna use the clock as that 17th
piece and something to note here is that
as the board opens up the Bishops will
be very strong so I'm looking at this
position I think that serious H7 uh
staring at G7 is important Knight to F5
at any moment the queen can go towards
the king side or even go back to A2 and
just stare at the center and stop those
black Pawns in their tracks I do feel
like the eval bar suggests black is much
better I think it's harder to play in
practice
yeah Queen B6 nice move though by Arjun
he's now threatening to go B3 and B2 and
here Jan has a tough decision to make do
you go Knight B3 blocking the pawns
while it's possible but then you
completely get rid of all of your
attacking ideas for his Knight at five
you can also get another five here but
then there's the move B3 for origin so
John really has a decision to make here
and he's he's gonna have to burn some
bridges
I don't like defending passively so I'd
be much more tempted to play Knight F5
you might just scare your opponent RJ
might see some ghosts there uh there are
Knight takes G7 ideas with queen G4 and
queen to the H file to follow that H7
Pawn can be quite loose in some of these
lines
yeah I like the purpose Knight of five
here and after B3 maybe bishop D4 in
between making sure that your Bishop
remains active on that diagonal and
after the creamus then like you said
there are ideas of Knight takes G7 and
queen G4 Queen H5 to follow so Jan
certainly has some attacking potential
here with the two Bishops on these long
diagonals I have a line for you Benjamin
Knight F5 if B3 from black maybe C5 for
white because white I've seen black
queen is overloaded so Knight takes C5
will be a problem with Bishop D4 to
follow and if you move somewhere white
plays Pawn to C6 because there are
tactics with 97 check in all these lines
oh that's a nice one that's a nice one
so let's point it out real quick so
let's say net of five after B3 there is
the move C5 and if you go let's say
queen E6 there is C6 forking the bishop
and the Knight and if you take the pawn
you take and if you take the queen there
is another fork and you win the queen
with white so very nice lines there by
by Robert but instead rugby one was
chosen by Yon
makes a lot of sense he's just stopping
the pawn before I can push up the board
the engine doesn't like it but I think
we as humans understand it but what's
the follow-up for black because you
can't push your Pawn to A2 I would be
nervous to do that I don't like pushing
my Pawn so far ahead of the other where
I can't keep them protected passers
yeah and I'm sure they can easily become
blocked maybe Knight C5 to prepare that
B3 push again and in case upon 65 you
can then also stick on D3 followed by
Bishop to A6 the question of course is
what is going to happen after Knight F5
it looks less scary if you start
stealing the Bishops so he plays Knight
to C5 Knight to five Knight takes D3 as
you point out that still looks very nice
for black I have a hard time imagine
imagine excuse me the black king getting
checkmated with just like one Knight on
F5
yeah now I have the I have the same
thing I think yawn should have gone for
a couple moves ago with 95 instead of
rugby one rugby one just seems a little
bit too slow and here look at this
Robert he's just taking the pawn on C4
and now Arjun has three connected
passers on the queen side
and if Queen takes C4 your Bishop A6
looks like a problem and you win The
Rook on F1 for your Bishop that's an
extra exchange for black maybe that's
White's best option because I can't
believe you can lit we live in a world
where you can allow three past pawns
just rumbling up the board and survive
so I think perhaps you just take on C4
go down the exchange and just pray that
Arjun goes wrong somewhere
yeah but I don't see it I mean that's
according to C4 what do you do do you go
Queen takes B4 well we'll find us very
soon but here Arjun can just trade
everything off take on B4 taking a form
play Rook FBA try to trade at the Rooks
as well this looks like a win for Arjun
this looks easy at this stage because
there's a passport in A3 and there's no
threats against the black king uh Rook
B8 was played and of course Jan avoids
it I'm looking at the clock arjun's
actually ahead on time so no worries
there for him either
great game so far by origin what about
the move A2 here Robert if you take the
Knight of C5 there's Rook B1 and you're
gonna pick up the bishop on B1 or you're
gonna get a new Queen and this looks
over and the computer even gives it a
brilliant move
I think it is because if you retreated
with your knight suddenly young would
feel like he has some chances to survive
but after this line with the Rook
slamming down on B1 you end the game
immediately because you can't take that
rook and if you move your Bishop to say
C3 the Black Knight comes into D5 and it
attacks that Bishop to get rid of it so
you can promote your Pawn
and if this was over I mean and we see
John rosini it's a great game about
Arjun and he's now taking the lead to
the one
and Jan cannot tilt it's just a one
point spread right now it's not a big
deal so we saw yesterday Wesley was up
seven to two and then Ali Reza stormed
back in the three plus one to win that
portion seven to two the flip the flip
script the script flipped whatever it is
that's what happened but he's going back
to his trusty French I'm a hater of the
French defense how do you feel about the
opening choice
yes he goes into the winner variation of
the of the French so so why do you hate
it have you ever played it with white or
with black or where does that the hate
come from
I've played against it as the from the
white side a ton I played it two times
in my life that I can remember with
black I have a one very you know career
highlight moment from the black side of
the French I played against Vichy so
that was a happy memory but I just don't
like what happens to the light Square
Bishop on C8 it's a bad piece I now it's
gonna get traded that's the good news if
uh Bishop comes to A6 you get rid of
your worst piece but in so many French
defenses you just have this horrible
bishop and white gets all the space
exactly so let's see if he's going to go
between six here origin anticipates the
move Bishop so so now he can go Bishop
to B5 and as we take this Knight on B it
can no longer go to C6 however often you
can solve that issue by going for a very
quick A6 move trying to get rid of the
pawn Young on the other hand goes A5 and
look at the clock forward he's still
playing Super quickly and this is what I
like I think the French defense came as
a bit of a surprise for Arjun and Jan
again has taken the lead on the clock
yeah and for young the French defense is
one of his trust trusty weapons like
Wesley so Wesley grew up playing the
French they know it extremely well and
now that we've seen a take on A6 in the
King has castled I don't see this being
a problem for black in fact the
underlying structure of the French is
good for black if you get to certain end
games look at those double Pawns of the
C file that's an issue that black knight
can now go up to C6 and A5 and C4 and
suddenly white does not have good
control of some key squares
yeah for sure the one thing though for
Yawn is that he first still has to take
this Pawn on A6 and after you you do
you're not on A6 is going to be slightly
misplaced so then you're gonna have to
come with a way to solve that we see
Argent taking the pawn on C5 interesting
decision and I wonder what Jana is going
to do he recaptures the B Pawn now
especially black is a big structural
Advantage so maybe origin has to go all
out on the king side he would remove
like H5
yeah he is the only one with the dark
squared Bishop so H5 followed by H6
would carve out those squares so Jan
plays H6 himself but there's good news
that the king is uncastled for white it
got an exclamation point because
allowing H6 would be too problematic but
Benjamin G4 G5 hello that looks like a
king side attack how will black stop
that
I don't know I think he just has the
loud so G4 let's see what he's gonna do
maybe just Rook takes a six take stakes
and after G5 maybe you can create some
quick counter play yourself with Queen
A5 but it seems like White's play on the
king side is coming pretty quickly but
perhaps after G5 what if you taking I
mean taking out of five there's H6 so I
don't know we see Queen into the origin
hanging on for the Paul hang on to the
pawn for now
but the reason I don't love that move is
because of this response now Rook takes
A6 will swap Rooks and then when the
queen takes back on A6 white is not
trying to trade Queens you don't go G4
and hope to trade Queens you don't ruin
your own Pawn structure on the C file
and hope to trade Queens the end games
will be favorable for black so unless
there's a move that I'm missing here I
don't like that Queen E2 decision it
allows the Queens to get in contact with
one another
right and right now Arjun isn't a tough
situation he might realize that G4 is
the way to go to create counter play on
the king side however we see that he's
already down two minutes on the clock
and going into wild complications while
you're so far behind and your opponent's
playing quickly and confidently is not
something that that's easy to do he goes
Rook A4 with the idea to go Rook G4 and
bring some more Firepower in the attack
but this is an idea that's so easily
parried Bishop takes H6 is a threat the
G7 Pawn is pinned the Knight on F5 will
sit there and be an incredibly strong
piece and then the Knight on B8 goes out
to C6 and maybe over to E7 to reinforce
it this looks strategically winning for
black so white needs to find a way to
force some issues here otherwise if
black chord hits everything it's big
trouble for Arjun
right I would say that origin finally
castles the problem for him was that
rookie one is coming very quickly
forcing White Castle so he figured that
he might as well just play that move
right away rookie two nice move by yawn
putting some pressure on the pawn on A2
and maybe now he can follow with the
move Queen A6 our finger trade of Queens
why does the move their Queen but I
don't really see comfortable Square to
Move It To Me Maybe D1 but that's not
very active and then black is going to
follow up with a move 96 that you
mentioned so right now it's looking like
it's all yarn upon yachi who has a two
minute lead on the clock and a nice
position on the board
and we see Knight H4 and then Queen A6
Yan says let's get those Queens off the
board it got it question mark I don't
mind it so much it's not objectively the
best move but it's one that makes
perfect sense and I look at this Arjun
he's so committed to the king side
attack he puts his Pawn on C4 but
there's something that Jan is relying on
if Knight takes F5 e takes F5 the queen
on A6 protects the H6 Pawn all the way
from that side of the board
way but right now it isn't Ken origin
taken F5 taken H6 sack The Rock Queen
takes you are turning Checkmate is that
a possibility Robert
I love the idea of it if it works that
is I think it does work I actually think
that Jan just walks into this tactic
yeah because after G6 you can also take
the rookie first or spontix G6 and
origin is going down that line Bishop 66
Bishop takes H6 is on the board so let's
see what John is going to do here this
looks this looks very critical for black
and it's a move that's so easy to
overlook your Pawn is attacking a rook
of course they have to move the Rook no
great awareness from you and from Arjun
pod G4 Queen G4 that actually looks
losing for black I don't really think
you're gonna survive that with the King
being ripped open but is there even
another move here Knight D4 is like a
hitting a queen on E2 and the bishop on
H6 and The Rook on G4 and after Rook
takes G7 check King h8 I don't see an
immediate checkmating attack but it
looks scary for black
it looks scary for black for sure but
the bishop 186 is hanging your queen on
e2's hangers hole so you're gonna have
to defend that maybe Queen D2 is there a
move like F4 for black without either
that in case you think of the queen
there is a move 92 with four there's
Bishop takes but then you hang the rook
and G7 so nepo he goes for 94 has he
figured out that variation
I think he has he kind of shook his head
that deserves an exclamation point to
kind of blunder let's be honest he
blundered Bishop takes H6 he didn't see
it coming but then to regain your
composure and play Knight D4 and work
through these tactics Benjamin look at
how much time he's up as well
yeah for sure and this is a nice thing
for now but even though he is blundered
this movie takes two chicks he can
invest some time recuperate and then
still find a way to keep the game going
so let's see what origin's gonna do
better Queen E3 runs into F4 and your
queen is under attack so then in case
you take again there's King takes G7 so
I think Queenie 2 is a little bit better
to make sure that F4 no longer comes for
the tempo
and he goes for that but look at how
quickly Jan plays F4 what is the best
move here for white Rook G4 you take the
bishop maybe there's Rook G6 so that
when black takes the Rook on G6 white
takes the Rook on f8 this is so messy
yeah I think that is the line he has to
go for is there the material remains
even black though has no broken C2 at
the end again you can still not take the
pawn on the four there's a fork on E2
and there we have Rook G6 on the board
is John instantly plays Queen xc4 and
look at this Robert he's now fully
pressuring origin on the clock he has
some tricky Eddies in some positions he
could consider taking on F1 followed by
Rook A1 for the moment though white is
Queen moment you have to be extremely
careful with white here
an E6 played by Arjun he's down under 15
seconds whoa and Jan goes for the
queenless ending here what what two what
what it was not made I think he could
still have gone for that no oh my gosh
of course he could have and he should do
that but maybe he thought the ensuing
end game was going to be lost but this
is clearly lost
yeah you're just getting checkmated here
in the next couple of moves wow what was
that and John evens up the score Robert
that's a shocker I think he could have
just taken amid rookie one with Queen E1
yeah that's what he had to do and even
if somehow black goes up a pawn in that
variation because the H5 Pawn was loose
clearly that's better than what happened
in the game so arjun's time trouble I
think played a part in his decision
there maybe he he felt like he needed to
rush it he overlooked the tactic but I
think for Yan that was really great
recovery he had lost two games in a row
he missed Bishop takes H6 and yet he
still found a way to win the game
exactly he came back in this match with
the French defense and what does Arjun
do he plays the French as well we see
nepo going for a different approach he
plays the advanced variation and I like
what he's doing here Robert he plays the
movie A4 to expand on the Queen's head
and now he wants to go in Knight A3 with
the idea to go Knight B5 and the
question is what do you do with black do
you go A6 well then you create Targets
on a queen side maybe I can go for B4
followed by B5 there so uh I I like the
opening here for young
I'm with you this looks very pleasant
for white because White's initiative on
the queen side is much more obvious than
whatever Black's going to do on the king
side for example for black you want to
play Rook G8 G5 H5 throw all your pawns
at the board that's never going to work
out white has the bishop on E2 Queen on
D1 staring through the diagonal so I
just feel like the the clear initiative
is for white and black has to deal with
those threats and then somehow come up
with a way to attack of his own
exactly so instead of A6 by origin
stopping the 95 jump perhaps now just B4
by Young trying to break open a queen
side as quickly as possible and there we
have it right away Robert I cannot
describe this position as any other way
than saying that this is a yawn upon
your sheep position he's got a slight
initiative here and the moves are
flowing in very easily
it really is and it's also an Argent era
geising position but if he had the white
pieces I don't think Arjun likes
defending it's not something that most
players enjoy although some are really
good at it but here it just seems like a
free hand on the queen side but Argent
goes Knight F5 and now the big question
can you push these Queen side pawns but
B5 might be met with A5 to shut the
queen side down
exactly Arjun wants to keep these files
closer B5 will probably be meant by A5
you can consider going B6 there though
to open up the the queen said he goes
Bishop G4 right away
trying to put pressure on the Knight on
F5 does he want to take and take on D5
certainly possibility let's see what he
has in my maybe Arjun should just
continue here with a move like Bishop to
E7
looks completely reasonable and the key
is the bishop on F4 is not defended if
it was then Bishop F550 E6 would just
win a piece for white but black would be
able to steal that Bishop on F4 and
Arjun once again down a minute 20
seconds every game it feels like Jan is
pressing him on the clock and it's bad
news especially in a position like this
yeah for sure so let's see what he's
going to do I mean taking on B4 looks
very questionable as wide has Rook C1
and after Bishop C6 a nice move Robert a
knight to B5 attacking the queen and I
guess it takes takes the bishop on C6 on
our attack so he goes Knight H6
attacking that Bishop on G4 perhaps he
was really worried that John was gonna
take in a five
and Jan probably will not take on H6 I
don't think because that hands black the
bishop hair and an open G file there's
not gonna be a Checkmate down that line
but the E5 Pawn is very very tender and
if you have to make moves like F4 to
defend it now all of your dark squares
are weak and only black would have a
dark Square Bishop so I would not take
on H6 I don't think uh and Jan says I'm
not gonna do that let's just go for the
attack
yeah he does not care about the bishop
Arjun can take here but the problem is
after Queen takes it's also going to be
difficult to develop that Bishop on f8
if you go Bishop B7 there's Queen takes
G7 and there's not a very colorful way
to defend that 27 so let's see
what origin is going to do I think the
move A5 looks like the most natural move
to me just keeping the queen side closed
for now
but your point is well taken A5 B6 is
what you should play especially if this
were bullet chess you throw that pawn up
the board and Jan he's doing that chest
Player thing he's looking away but he's
really calculating can I throw that pawn
up the board give it away to open a file
yeah let's see if he's gonna go for it
and there we have it B6 nice move by
Young now rugby one attacking the queen
of this move and then there's gonna be
Knight B5 what uh what a great game so
far by Young
every move has had a purpose and now the
B5 square is carved out for his pieces
Bishop E2 comes with Tempo against that
Queen but maybe black wants C5 to C4
it's a committal move in terms of the
pawn shops here but it opens up that
Bishop on f8 so Bishop E2 it's a one
move threat probably not the way to go
but there could be tactics with
sacrifices and things of that nature
it's going to heat up here
yeah for sure and Robert what about this
bishop takes a chicks followed by C4 it
gives like a tough decision you can take
this poem and then Queen C2 he goes
Knight B5 now black and goes C4 and
Bishop C5 and has a little bit more room
to breathe
that looks reasonable but C4 would be
met by Queen D4 potentially just trying
to stop your Bishop C5 idea uh Rook G8
looks very normal to my eyes but maybe
your C4 for white just keeping that
Bishop under f8 stuck and trying to open
up the position for your pieces it feels
like the black king is not going to be
happy to see that move C4
yeah I like the move C4 as it
potentially opens up this diagonal for
the light Square Bishop like we said it
also stops C4 from black to bring this
bishop into the game so let's see if Jan
is going to go for it again it's it's
another typical yawn upon yashi move
and the issue I would say are the
downside of playing C4 for white is it
opens up that diagonal not just for
White's Bishop but for Black's Bishop
because the G2 Pawn could be a potential
Target so it's a very committed decision
and that's why Yan is correctly spending
his time and I sort of want to correct
the record about Jana palmchini
sometimes he's a reputation for playing
too fast which is true but he knows when
to conserve his time and when to spend
it and he does spend it before playing
C4 correctly correctly evaluating
assessing that this is good for white
yeah nice move here by John I think in
case black takes you should be you
should wait for a second to play The
Move F3 because if you do black
gets Bishop C6 so maybe in case black
takes you play Move like Queen E2 first
trying to regain a pawn black can not go
Bishop C6 just yet as it hangs the E6
spawn of his check and you pick up the
Rook so let's see how Arjun is going to
deal with the spawn sacrifice it goes
Bishop p7 but what does he have in mind
in case white just takes here
he's gonna take back I guess and the
bishop on G4 is under threat so he wants
to trade pieces and his claim is that
well he's up two pawns on C5 and D5 but
then white gets these past spawns of his
own so Benjamin it's it's a race do the
C and D pawns do they shine or is it
gonna be the f e pawns I'm not sure
yeah good question let's see what's
going to happen maybe just Queenie two
keeping the status quo preparing to take
on D5 at some point and black doesn't
have any easy moves you cannot move the
bishop you're gonna hang this moving the
d-pawn has its drawbacks as well perhaps
there's King B8 to slowly improve the
position and there we have to move
Queenie two by Young
I feel like you're the young Palm she
Whisperer right now you're really
calling his moves and he's playing with
Force so I like the way this is
happening and it's non-committal and
that's a good thing right now when Arjun
only has a minute and a half on his
clock this is clearly a trickier
position to figure out for black
yeah so let's see what he's gonna do
maybe just King B8 although perhaps
Robert he has not easy to take on D5
followed by E6 attacking the bishop and
then Queen E5 that that looks pretty
scary for black
that looks nasty I would not want any
part of that of course that Bishop would
love to take the Knight on B5 but then
their E6 point is too loose so that
doesn't look very good not to mention
Rook takes B5 Rook B1 the B7 Pawn is in
danger so I don't actually see a move
here I'm gonna be honest I don't see a
move that I would want to play as black
yeah and this is such a tough situation
for Arjun like he knows he has to move
right he's got a minute on his clock his
clock is ticking but it's like what do
you play right you're like I gotta move
I gotta move but but what are you
actually doing he comes up with the move
Rook to G6 all right okay but now in
case it take stakes and uh F4 would
always come with with tempo
and John apparently missed something and
Rook F to D1 but the evaluation is still
in his favor so perhaps he takes D5 was
more forceful but Rook fd1 to my eyes
looks like another improving move if
Rook doubles on the G file you bring
your Bishop back to F3 defending the G2
pawn and striking in the center
yes sir because you're a nice move by by
John he's keeping the pressure on origin
and he finally decides to take on C4 so
let's see who John is going to do here
you can recapture the queen you can
slide your Bishop back to F3 lots of
tempting options also Knight D6 is there
so I think we're gonna see John
investing a little bit of time here
again
and Bishop F3 is so powerful because
Bishop C6 is not really available to
black as if there are swap on C6 you
can't take with the queen because Knight
A7 check would be a nasty Fork
right can you take out the beep on
though I know it weakens the black king
but I I don't see the median knockout
just yet ah but I can't even look at
that pawn show look at the Double H
pawns the triple isolated oh my goodness
we're about to see this Pawn structure
right and there we have it on the board
Look Away Ladies and Gentlemen so now
what do you do he goes 96 right away I
guess he just wants to recapture with
the pawn looks good for white but for
now black is still keeping it together
and there's gonna be a queen B2 at some
moment like ed6 it runs Queen B2 with
Queen B8 Checkmate or the queen maybe
even jumping to h8 if the Rook leaves
the back rank there's all sorts of
threats here and he does take with the
pawn the king slides out to D7 how do
you get to that King
good question or I mean maybe Queen has
three to go Queen F7 but again look at
the clock Origins got 17 seconds it's
gonna be so tricky for him to keep this
one together Jan at some point can also
just go Pawn grabbing and be like hey
miking is safe over here black scene is
weak so he should always have the
advantage so let's see how he's gonna
work his magic here
Rook B2 what a quiet move especially in
your opponent's time Travel King to E8
does the king actually get to escape I
don't think so they might even have D7
check in that position or queen E5 as
you're pointing out so Rook to G5 Rook
D5 is Black's next move that would help
save the king
yeah sure there'll be a nice move for
origin so let's see what Jana's gonna do
maybe rookie won targeting the pawn on
E6 which is now unaffinity goes queen of
three is Rook D5 a move or are there
some scary tactics right maybe someone
like checking rookie one and why you
gotta move off with one second
barely gets it off and now it's E6 under
threat he goes Queen see it with just a
second on his clock there's no Checkmate
right now
but it started to move Rook B8 attacking
the queen he goes rugby seven rookie
about Arjun for now he's keeping
everything together and he's up a couple
of Pawns Robert has young let this one
slip watch out for those triple pawns
they can go up to C3 and C2 and cause
back rank problems for the white king I
don't see a Checkmate Queen F4 check the
only move for black is E5 you could take
on H6 after that short but then maybe
The Rook slides up to E6 this feels like
one of those Sam Lloyd puzzles where
there should be a Checkmate but I just
don't see it
goes Rook A7 but C3 nice one by origin
E5 can you take the Palm but rookie six
are queen okay I guess you take the pawn
on each other but whatever rookies seven
here and at least yo 0.2 seconds when he
made the move
what is going on okay y'all also in a
very long time
okay he's gotta move he goes Rook c one
and Arjun lost long time wow Robert what
a game Jan was out playing origin but in
the one position Arjun had the advantage
he loses on time
and that's what happens when you're down
to your dwindling seconds even when you
play Perfect Defense as Arjun did there
was that one moment where Rook C1
suddenly froze him he couldn't make his
move in time so unfortunate for our
generic icy but I win there for yawn
apology he hunted that King he was
persistent
right and we see we saw that Arjun was a
little bit red out there I wonder if
perhaps he lost the connection there or
maybe he had a little bit of light there
for a second or maybe he just had
trouble getting that move off in time
it's it's so easy Roberts with the one
second increment to to lose on time
especially when you have only 1.2
seconds for your move but you can regain
time on the clock Arjun was doing such a
good job of that but unfortunately for
him he now Trails three to two and we
have another fun position a H Pawn push
seemingly out of nowhere Benjamin I have
not seen this exact position before what
do you make of what's going on
yeah so pretty interesting opening we
see that black has the best repair
however the position is fairly closed
and I think the idea behind move H4 by
origin is to restrict this bishop a
little bit it can no longer go to G5
also he perhaps wants to go G3 and
Bishop H3 to trade off these light
squared Bishop all of black spawns are
on the dark squares white spawns are on
the light squares meaning that this
bishop on F1 doesn't have a whole lot of
scope and therefore would make a lot of
sense to trade it off but but we see a
pretty interesting move here by Young he
goes Bishop to d8 and I wonder if he
somehow wants to activate this bishop on
one of these diagonals I have a funny
move for you he went F5 which makes
perfect sense and that I don't know how
that move gets a question mark it looks
very good but I'm wondering if we could
just bring up an analysis board for a
second and Rook B3 is played so my idea
is no longer relevant but his Queen
takes B2 possible here because Rook B3
can be met by Bishop A5 and I was
wondering once you take the queen on B2
Bishop C3 check does black have
sufficient compensation the answer
apparently is not full compensation but
you have that Lasker compensation of
Rook minor piece and pawn for a queen
exactly I think it was definitely worth
consideration especially if White had to
go King E2 so perhaps that's why Arjun
played Bishop to uh to E2 but we have
more moves Robert F5 was played so we
see Rook B3 Queen C7 we see trade and F5
Bishop G4 and C4 I like it for I like it
for now I like it for yawn I think he's
creating sufficient counter play maybe
now Queen B6 Queen xb2 is a real threat
as there's no longer the move for B3 and
also the queen is eyeing the opponent F2
what does Arjun even do here
this looks problematic he decides to
swap Bishops which probably means Knight
E4 is coming he plays that but Queen
takes B2 is a free Pawn although the
engines say great move from origin it
was the right way to defend F2 but
Benjamin that's a pawn that's hanging
and how is y gonna respond
yeah it's pretty incredible after Queen
xb2 maybe white just moves the rook and
answer Bishop A5 you can just play C3 or
King E2 and even though it looks
terrible at first glance you're down
upon your king is being attacked maybe
it's not too bad there
oh Rook F4 got a question mark but it
also looks like a pretty natural move
you're hitting the Knight and the H4
Pawn but white has all of his forces
towards the king side Knight E2 comes
with Tempo kicking that Rook away I feel
like suddenly white is feeling much
happier with much more space and control
and black is the one who's
underdeveloped in the queen side
yeah so let's see what John's gonna do
there after 92 you can perhaps take the
pawn on H4 but like you said black is
behind he goes Knight H3 uh so I guess
in case black takes maybe you just go
castles white is down two pawns for the
moment but this rook in H4 is somewhat
misplaced but it's got a nice night here
on e4 which is attacking the pollen D6
so uh yeah white certainly has
commentation there
in general do you prefer to have the
material advantage or the quote-unquote
compensation when you're playing Blitz
often I like to take pawns but I think
you know in Blitz it might make a lot of
sense to to just go for the attack and
insect a sacrifice upon her too Bishop
E6 by net by by art by by young but what
in case what happens in case why just
sex
uh that's probably really good for white
there's also that Knight retreating back
to F5 at the right moment the black king
is clearly in a vulnerable spot the
White Queen will jump out to F3 Knight
takes D6 looks like it's really going to
hurt you on here
yeah it looks scary for black I mean
there's also the move Knight F5 attack
in The Rook if you combine it with a
move like Queen G4 the King on G it can
come under serious fire so perhaps young
played a little bit too quickly here
and
Arjun just made the move Rook to G3 he
lost most of his advantage and you can
see Jan's face he was confused by this
but Rook takes E4 is the queen H5
followed by Knight G5 things of that
nature
yeah that looks nice for riding his
route 64 there's Queen H5 threatening
Checkmate on E8 and it keeps going 97 I
think there's Knight G5 you attacked the
Roku E4 you hit the pawn on F7 in case
of Knight F6 you give a check can you
trade you take the rook and there will
be Checkmate on G7 at the end so I think
young really has to bring in some
defensive forces with the move at Knight
to D7
he does just that and your Aero game is
super strong I just have to give you the
credit that it's due uh he's drawing all
those arrows I'm keeping up with you I
hope the audience is as well and now
that we're under the Midway point I'm
curious let's get chat involved once
again it's three to two in John's favor
do you still think that Jan is the
favorite do you think that Arjun will be
able to take this match let's hear your
thoughts please get involved but Ben
Benjamin here Knight takes D6 is played
and the engine doesn't like the pawn
grabbing
yeah Rook Cafe nice move by Young
perhaps there was something better for
origin maybe move like Knight G5 again
then I could move to E6 Rook G4 by
origin trying to trade up the one pair
of Rooks in case you take their screen
takes G4 attacking the Knight and you
also threaten to slide into E6 so that
looks scary for yawn so maybe he just
has to play to move rocket shakes
attacking the Knight on D6
retreating moves are always difficult to
play but here it makes perfect sense you
kick that Knight out of there C4 is
loose that is true but that Bishop on B6
The Rook on f8 they're doing good work
in the position aiming at the white king
side but what happens after Rook H6
Knight takes C4 where is the black queen
going to
good question I mean I guess you to
either C3 or A2
I guess we'll find out very soon if Yawn
is going to play then move I mean I
don't see what else he's gonna do taking
on G4 to me looks extremely scary bring
the queen out into the attack so rookie
chicks to me looks like the move
I'm with you it's better to save your
king than worry about where your queen
is going to go to he does play Rook H6
Knight takes E4 and queen C3 we see a
quick swap of pieces on B6 so now we
have a position where if my math is
correct it's even material all of a
sudden but White's King even though it's
not perfectly safe does feel safer
because Knight E6 is a big threat Pawn
to D6 at any moment can hurt especially
opening up that diagonal towards the
black king Benjamin I would take white
here but black is recording the engines
doing okay
yeah I think arjun's got a pretty nice
position materials even like you said
and he's got the initiative he's also
got moves like 94 taking a queen
uh followed by perhaps that move these
six that you you mentioned so let's see
what John is going to do here it's it's
not looking easy at all if this queen
would ever give a check on the long
diagonal that looks deadly
whoa E4 played he wants to open up the
diagonal towards the white king if
Knight takes E4 there's likely some kind
of queen A5 business threading mate
threading the D5 Pawn so here Arjun
needs to tread carefully I would go
forward Knight E6 is very tempting but
you do have to deal with Queen E5
yeah I think E4 makes a lot of sense
from from John especially from a
practical standpoint so let's see what
origin is going to do he could of course
also take this Pawn With The Rook make
sure the black can no longer go go Queen
E5 Knight E6 like you said makes a lot
of sense attacking the rook and the pawn
G7 do you just play Rook F7 there or
perhaps you do go Queen E5 give up the
pawn and G7 and go King in shade let's
find out
such a tough call at this moment and he
does take the pawn on e4 so Arjun who is
down two pawns suddenly up one that's a
big turnaround in terms of material and
the black Rook on H6 is doing a great
job of attacking and defending but
what's the follow-up here Jan he seems
to be struggling to find his next idea
yeah you would love to somehow line up
the queen in The Rook on the HR but I
don't see a good way to do it Knight C4
makes sense he wants to go Knight D6 and
bring the Knight back into the game but
I don't know it's all looking a little
bit loose onions and maybe now move like
rookie 6 preparing to get that move D6
in oh that way you can push your Pawn
I'm gonna Queen D4 trying to swap the
queen stuff I think you have to trade
Queens because your knight on C4 is
loose and white is a pawn ahead so why
not go into this end game
right but I feel like the end game might
be holdable for black after let's say
trait and Knight D6 White's got these
weaknesses on the queen side C2 is a
little bit quick A4 as well so perhaps
origin has to go first chances in the
middle again where like we said black
skin and Jade does feel someone
vulnerable Robert he's getting down to
40 seconds so he has to be extremely
careful here
and he plays Queen D4 I think it's
because of the time but that rookie six
idea is something that Arjun would have
seen he didn't know how to assess it
properly so Queen D4 is clear he is
going to be up a pawn and if yon plays
Perfect Defense great the draw is going
to be made but of course origin has very
good chances to win this game
y'all know he has to trade on D4 he has
to play it quickly as well to keep the
pressure on origin and perhaps on Knight
D6 and there we have it maybe Arjun
should play Move like 94. he goes C4
preparing to go C5 what about Rook C8
here
so Roxy wanted B6 is their A5 is he
gonna sacrifice his a pawn to push
through CMD
that looks great I mean why not I don't
see your A5 save the pawn you go C5
after and these spawns are rolling up
the board this looks great for right
and look at this it's even material
that's what people would think but I
look at this as it's essentially extra
two pawns for white and just these
double A pawns for black that aren't
going anywhere I'll just bring that Rook
back as you're highlighting then bring
your knight into the game push C and D
pawns as you see fit Jan is in big
trouble but he's doing a good job of
chasing White's pieces
and or I could try to take the Knight of
G5 let's see where the knight's gonna go
or it's not going to go anywhere origin
plays F4 and Knight E6 okay now he's
ready to go D6 and D7 so maybe king of
seven nice move by by uh young stopping
white from playing D6 for now and what a
frustrating moment because it seems like
white should be winning and now the a
pawn it could sacrifice itself A4 A3 and
just distract the white Rooks
G4 Rook H3 Jan is so resilient for the
moment white cannot play D6 he goes at
five strength in the night but what
about Knight C3 here attacking The Rook
The Rook doesn't have a very good
squaring case rookie two there's a four
so Rook D4 he goes Rook C3 instead
and he wants a swap works and gone for
the D5 Pawn or taking a 94 check that
white Rook on D14
D6 and Rook D1 at the end
yes and you can't you don't have time to
play Kingdom G3 because A3 A2 is
happening he's chasing the pawn down but
that means the Knight is passive he
should be the losing move
apparently black was winning after King
E5 with the Eddie to go King D5 and king
of four he goes to H5 now if anything
young can win this let's see if Arjun
can hold the draw
I think King F3 was precise at that
moment and nope oh this is table based
draw at this stage the white king going
to the a pawn and the Knight will chase
the Jeep on
yeah apparently you're just in time to
pick up the the A2 pawn and bring your
knight back to the defense your g393 and
you're just in time
wow and if that were an H Fawn instead
of a g-pawn maybe some of it would have
been trickier but this is well known
stuff Yan he shakes his head he I don't
know why he shaking his head because
he's lucky that he was able to uh secure
this draw here
yeah he's so resilient Robert he had a
win in this position he had that move
King E5 with Daddy to go king of four
and King D5 if you go King up I guess
you go King here King C4 so that was a
big missed Opportunity by Yan pomyoshi
as we see he still had around like 26
seconds on his clock so perhaps if he
invested a little bit of time he would
have found it
and you saw Jan he's still shaking his
head Arjun leaves his chair the players
they get to take a break but you're
right Benjamin there was that one moment
where it looks like Jan could have won
the game he couldn't find it it didn't
happen but yonda Palm she still leads
this match by a point Benjamin what do
you think of what we've seen thus far
yeah it's been a very up and down match
I think overall young does have the
upper hand that being said it feels like
origin is very capable of uh of mounting
combex so perhaps Jan has to find a way
to play a little bit more solid and keep
his lead when he when he has one
wow and what a start in this match Arjun
he was able to storm back after losing
the first game then Jan was able to win
two in a row himself so this has been
trading wins for these sides it's a
decisive Affair we'll see who can
continue in good form but before we head
to break just like the players we want
to remind everybody of what month it is
it's September but it's also September
so it's that time of year through the
end of this month claim up to 30 off all
new Subs on Twitch subscribers gain
access to exclusive break time content
during broadcast unlock new emotes use
those yawned upon that she heads spam
Danny wrench emotes Go With It mittens
and even more score an ad for experience
at chess.com don't miss out on the deals
this September subscribe right now but
right now I will be back along with
Benjamin Bach this is the speeches
Championship presented by coinbase and
this is the match between Jana
Palmerston Arjun Air Guys do not go
anywhere
[Music]
foreign
Andrea and I'm Alex and we've been
playing competitive chess since we were
six years old
we started by focusing on classical
chess but later we fell in love with
playing Blitz and bullet online
chess has been around for more than 1
000 years but that doesn't mean that we
can't modernize it Financial systems
have been around for even longer sounds
like it's time for an update and
coinbase is doing just that
re-envisioning an entirely new Financial
system that is decentralized and fully
transparent
also huge thank you to coinbase for
sponsoring competitive chess and making
events like the SCC happen go to
coinbase.com update the system to learn
more
love playing chess variants or just
looking for something new join us for
the variants Community series
every two months we'll be featuring a
different variant in a series of events
and competitions learn a new variant and
compete against other players for prize
money or just play for fun look for
Community Arenas streamer Arenas and
Championship events six weekly Arena
tournaments held every Thursday will be
followed by a championship event with
cash prizes including a one thousand
dollar first place prize the third and
final weekly Arenas will be streamer
Arenas featuring gifted Subs as prizes
when any of these events to qualify for
the championship the variants Community
series kicks off on September 7th with
King of the Hill where the first to
occupy the center wins the game but
getting checkmated still loses and join
the variants club today to learn more
about upcoming events how to participate
and much much more see you in the arena
on chess.com
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
presented by coinbase yonda Palm she
leads Arjun eragisi and Jan is no
stranger to the speed Chess Championship
he has had previous successes Benjamin
we see what he's up to right now but he
shouldn't forget about some of these
previous editions where he made it to
the semifinals
exactly yeah here we see that in the
2019 speeches Championship he beat ding
Loren in the quarter finals
unfortunately he would have loved to
beat him in another match and as you see
Robert all good runs come to an end when
you run into Hikaru Nakamura
we know Hikaru is the final boss he's
won five speeches championships in a row
and there is John the Palm I like
the artwork on his wall I feel like it's
quite a lively room there and his play
is always Lively
right and is that a samurai sword he's
looking pretty aggressive I guess
we know that Peter leco also has one of
those so maybe it's just these great
chess players have both of them have
played World Chess Championship matches
perhaps it's what you receive when you
unfortunately do not win
yeah no I guess that that is what
happens behind the scenes you know the
world champion gets crowned but the the
runarp gets a gets a sword so let's see
how it will help him in the second half
of this five plus one portion
yes and for Jana pomsi he wants more of
the same considering he has the lead and
for Arjun Eric geisey he needs to play I
think a little bit more quickly in the
early stages of the game because he was
defending tenaciously in that one game
where his King was out in the open but
he lost on time so as we look at this
opening oh well this looks like another
great fight
yeah so we see Arjun going for what is
called the pin variation if I'm not
mistaken of the Sicilian however Robert
from what I recall this is considered to
be quite dubious for black and young
still knows it this is always the
interesting thing Robert I think Jan for
the world championship you just look at
every single opening Under the Sun so
perhaps he's also looked at this one
it's funny because this does not happen
at the highest levels very often and in
some ways it resembles a French defense
look at these bad pawns for white on the
C file look at the E5 Pawn that's
hanging uh the only way that I can see
to defend both because Queen takes C3 is
a winning threads Queen G3 but then
black takes on C3 with the queen we see
the Queens come off the board Benjamin
that will be a pawn up for black
right but I feel like white should have
pretty good compensation in that end
game after all of the trades perhaps you
play a move like Bishop D2 attacking the
Knight the bishop can go to B4 also
there are always at least of let's say
Knight B5 with the knight jump into C7
or D6 so let's see when what John is
going to do I think Queen G3 definitely
looks like the move though
Queen G3 I feel like you have to you
don't want to give E5 that's way too
important of a pawn in the center so
give up your double isolated C3 Pawn
that would be the way to go but you
could see Jan is confused so even if he
knew the moves that were supposed to be
played he's probably not sure about the
assessment the evaluation of an end game
when he's down a pawn so he plays Bishop
D2 he sees that he'll have composition
here but whose side would you rather
have right now
I'm really surprised I mean I guess I
would rather have white you have easy
development the king and the Fate is
always going to be a problem but I'm
really surprised that he decided to give
the pawn on E5 which is a crucial which
is a crucial upon us now it's going to
be easier for Arjun to develop H5
kicking the queen away and here we see
Jan sacrificing another one but do you
take this one I don't know because
there's always going to be Bishop before
check to watch out for
there is zero chance I'm taking that
second Pawn in the center because what
Bishops need is open space with that
pawn on C3 you could say is it winning
material a good thing yes but it's also
good for pieces that are staring into
those pawns so the bishop would be happy
to see that C3 Pawn go bye-bye and if I
am Arjun I don't know what I do here
maybe Queen F6 but I think that young
will move his Queen away anyway but he
steps in the right direction and his the
E5 square is vacated for his Knight
and perhaps you wear origin there for a
second because he does play the move
queen of six offering the trade of
Queens I'm pretty sure that John is
going to keep the Queen's home but how
do you do it you go Queen E4 maybe then
Queenie five for black perhaps we could
have a repetition who knows and there we
have Queen E4 will we say queen E5
origin or maybe like 97 followed by D5
I like this repetition of queen queen E4
Queen E5 Queen F3 Queen F6 that is not
one you see often at all but what does
black do if not for that so you
mentioned rerouting tonight that makes a
lot of sense to me Knight D to E7 Pawn
to D5 but I feel like with the King on
f8 you're feeling a bit nervous okay or
not he doesn't feel nervous at all he
plays G5
what a move I was not expecting that one
at all and Rook if you want I'm slightly
surprised they don't play that one so
quickly with the pawn and G5 I would be
very tempted to go for F4 we see Knight
F4 by Arjun and we see young trading on
C6 very quickly I think this position
still favor Jean as it's just easier to
play Black is always going to have
problems with this King
and Knight takes E2 check could have
been thrown in just now but what Yan was
claiming is that opposite colored
Bishops we say end games that can be
drawers but when there's so many pieces
on the board the side with the safer
King is happy to have opposite colored
Bishops the King on f8 on a dark Square
would have been In Harm's Way so that
Knight on F4 is very important it's both
aggressive and it helps defend some of
the key squares for black
so you see Queen A4 by taking the policy
six E5 nice move by origin to defend it
and I don't know it feels like black is
getting more and more control of this
position the king will probably be
sitting pretty safely on G7 C4 by by
young but it doesn't do a whole lot and
I think after King G7 play something
pretty fine
yeah Bishop C3 attacks E5 but black
always says D4 to kick that Bishop off
the diagonal so the King on G7 is safe
it's such a weird position but suddenly
I love Black's pawns all of those on the
fifth rank
exactly yeah and it's going to be
difficult for why to kick this Knight
away in case you go G3 there might be
Knight H3 and also after that black can
go H4 to open up this h54 they're Rook
so we see Bishop 5 by Arjun also good
move bringing the bishop into the game
so let's see how nepo will try to work
his magic here I mean we know that he
always does find a way he goes Queen A5
but I wanna run the ideas perhaps Robert
he wants to take on D5 taking a four and
regain the D5 Pawn
that looks very strong he's trying to
collapse black center and that Queen can
also slide a C5 with check if the black
queen isn't looking out for it the C6
Pawn will be loose so I like what you're
pointing out here it seems like black
center is on the verge of collapsing but
maybe you'd have to get up the pawn
maybe you play King G7 allow white to
restore material equality and say at
least my king is safe
Robert I just wanted to point out I
think after King G7 hey he has this um
he has this
E5 followed by Bishop to C3 the bishop
is defended and there's no D4 as that
will hang the queen so I think that is
the idea Jan has a mind wow he tricked
me you tricked me I tricked myself but
let's show that let's bring up an
analysis board very quickly because it's
a beautiful tactical variation and it
does showcase the point of the queen
being on A5 that the black king slides
up you found the tactic Rook takes eight
E5 is so nice
exactly Bishop C3 wins the queen of
Bishop's defendant ending again in case
D4 there's Queen takes E5 so we see the
move Rook to C8 by Arjun bringing us
we're going to the game but I don't know
it looks a little bit slow and this
gives young some time to maybe take on
D5 and go C4 to break up the position
and it looks like John played Bishop to
C3 if we venture back to the live board
or that looks like a very natural move
but it is given a Miss I think your idea
uh was strong to try to play for more
open position but the bishop on C3 if D4
is the move your Bishop B4 check and E5
will fall so I guess you have to bring
your knight back to G6 it's not the
happiest move to play but it does keep
everything together
yes in 96 Playboy origin again Robert
look at the clock yawn up almost two
minutes maybe just move like Rook 81
bring the Rook into the game and
attacking the pawn on D5 this looks
tough and again John's moves comes so
easily the thing though is with janhi he
makes it look easy in a way because
before the position looks very messy but
somehow he finds his way through these
complications and it's impressive
it always is impressive watching gotten
upon machine such a speed demon in his
own right we have it talking earlier in
the show that Arjuna geisey may be the
favorite in bullet but we have seen it
be essentially a bullet for Arjun
against Blitz for yawn because Jan is
always ahead on the clock like he is by
a minute right now so it's not an easy
position he's trying to figure this out
uh do you take on D5 do you start with
Rook a to D1 black can take on C2 if
you're not looking out for it that
Bishop does stare at that pawn over
there and of course black wants King G7
but is that walking into some kind of
Rook takes E5 that's one of these
critical questions
right and Robert I was just wondering
after Rook 81 what happens after the
move d4 but perhaps we have time for
Rook takes D4 and queen C5 check with
the Adida now we take on D4 the queen is
on our attack the only score I can go to
is here and then we can take the rook
and we can pick up the bishop on a five
and all of a sudden we are up a pawn
maybe that is what nepo missed and he
played the move politics D5 followed by
Bishop A6 I don't know this doesn't wait
is this just a blunder
uh yes Rook takes C3 the queen is
overloaded
wait what I mean
you do have root takes E5 at the end
though with with a four Orchestra way
with Queen F6 and wait checking I think
you're just lost but that I think maybe
what yeah
oh he just blunted even more there's
still a check but I don't know he's
completely throwing this one away we'll
actually be able to finish this one off
but I can tell what John missed he saw
Queen F6 but I thought rookie a check
would win for him but the Knight on G6
protected The Rook on h8 which is what
allowed Arjun to go for this variation
Jan is upset with himself right now he
went for a tactical trip but he tricked
himself and now it looks like argent's
well on his way to evening up this match
but I'm still looking at the clock 33
seconds for Arjun a minute and 33
seconds for Yan that's a big time
advantage
for sure yes so let's see if he can
summow Arjun goes rookie it's
threatening to move d4 forking the queen
and the Rook so not looking easy here
for for John I think he's okay I was
just about to say I think if he wants to
swing the origin he has to keep the
Queens on the board but perhaps he feels
like he has the best chances in an end
game
well I don't think he has much chance in
the end game even with arjun's time
travels what Young wants to do though is
trade off the queen side pawns if the C
and A pawns are traded for the A and D
Pawns in all of the actions concert just
on the king side that will make his
chances better the reason why Bishop at
night are two pieces a rook is just one
they can team up on squares but they
need targets to attack
origin training of the Rocks okay so G3
nice move by Young attacking the Knight
H3 that looks a little bit off the
Knight is a little bit stranded over
here King G2 by by Young you cannot take
the because of Bishop B7 but maybe you
can go Rook B1 and try to go quickly
after this a pawn
that would be important he should go on
that side but Bishop comes back to F5
and the C2 Pawn would have been a Target
so that's why it goes King F1 he's ready
to take on D5 but oh that's such an
annoying move to face Bishop A6 to C4
Pawn goes up to A6 white can't attack
anything
yet everything is defended now look at
this Knight G5 origin with nada3 to
follow this one is going to be over
pretty soon like is everything protected
and now is creating his own attacks
he's threading a Checkmate D4 was
Checkmate if not for that pawn push to
C3 and okay well John is gonna go after
talking about there we have it on the
board oh my gosh
I thought I made one
yeah and origin levels up the score what
a game I mean it looked like NEPA was
doing his thing slowly but surely
increasing the pressure but all of a
sudden he completely threw it away with
that trade in D5 and Bishop A6 and now
we see a very topical variation Robert
with a quick Knight H5
yes this has been very popular in recent
years I just can't get overnight F1
Checkmate I don't think I've ever seen a
Checkmate quite like that before where
the bishop and Knight team up with the
help of the king
me neither yeah I think that's
definitely wanted to go into you know
the checkmating patterns books I I've
never seen it either and I like this
approach here by yawn I think he's
tackling the London in a much more
effective way why it has the more active
pieces but upon the foursome model is
isolated it's weak and the Knight on D2
is slightly misplaced normally you would
want it to be on C3 so I like the
opening here for young
I agree with you I think that black
doesn't have too much to worry about a
white can strike with D5 at some point
but the queen because the knights on D2
doesn't see to that D5 Square I mean you
need that Knight on C3 for white that
would be actually a very nice move if
the Knight were more active
D5 is so difficult to find a Robert idea
is that in case black takes you go
Bishop B5 attacking the the Knight and
I'm not surprised that he doesn't find
it let's pull that up real quick so
after the move B6 White had to move D5
in case black takes Bishop B5 attack in
the Knight and the problem is that if
you defend it white can take and go
Knight D4 attacking the bishop and the
Knight on H5 and if you take the bishop
on E5 then there is Knight takes
attacking the 9h5 and you also have the
third of Knight C6 so very difficult
move to find so that is why Arjun played
H3 but it feels like now Jan has a very
comfortable position
yeah that's a position that showcases
loose pieces dropping off the Knight on
H5 it's loose over there and in many of
these positions if black were to take on
E5 and the White Knight takes back if
the Black Knight goes back to F6 after
Knight takes E5 I'd be work at Knight G5
and a big attack so I think that the
Black Knight probably should go into F4
and that way you stop any sort of Knight
hops into the position
right so let's see if that is what he's
going to go for again yum before you
know before you blink he all of a sudden
is up a minute on the clock he goes
Knight F6 okay he's inviting that move
Knight G5 perhaps he wants to go Bishop
D5 stopping any sacrifices on these F7
and E6 points it feels like black should
have the advantage because they're
better Pawn structure oh if capablanca
we're playing this game I would say 0-1
signed the score sheets it's over and
the reason why is there's the isolated
Queen Pawn for white black has a bishop
pair and black controls the square in
front of the iqp that is essential you
want to blockade that square Benjamin
this looks strategically very bad for
white so that's why I'm trying to get
tactical with Knight G5 some kind of
sacrifice I just don't see how to make
it work
and he has to do something quickly if he
plays slow moves like let's say he
trades and he goes like 23 Rook 81 it
feels like black is a very good game
with the bishop pair the better Pawn
structure so I like your approach with
Knight G5 I think Bishop D5 is very
effective way to shut it down he goes
Knight C3 also possible to make it more
difficult for black to block it on that
D5 score but Rook seed it looks like a
very nice game here for for Yan ponyashi
who is now up uh 90 seconds of weight
and isn't this just a free Pawn
there are tactics with Bishop takes E6
and things like that so the engine it
went down in Black's favor clearly
Bishop takes E6 won't work out the way
it looks like it should I wonder it's
because the F2 F2 Pawn is loose in some
of these positions right The Rook on F
it opens up to that pawn on F2 there
might be tactics that actually go in
Black's favor but I wouldn't be
surprised if Jan says no I don't want to
take on D4 I'll make some kind of more
solid move
E6 you have a move like Bishop C5 but y
can take and go rookie 2 to keep this
defendant so I don't see it right away
for Yama yum certainly is thinking about
it so let's see if he will take
such a big choice and you know what's
good for Yan is that he has time to
calculate when he gets ahead on the
clock it means that he can calculate
critical moments he takes the pawn and
Bishop takes E6 seemed obvious and
Bishop C5 Benjamin you called it the F2
Pawn is loose the bishop on B7 with the
F2 Pawn because aims at the G2 Pawn for
checkmate double exclamed great
recognition by you and you on the palm
machine
right so y takes here on a seven King in
trade and I think the only way to
protect the pawn on F2 is a good rookie
too if you go Rook F1 you hang the
Knight on E5 Queen C2 I don't know it
doesn't look good but the question is
what does black have there after Rook to
E2 perhaps you have a move like Knight
H5 threatening going out of four and in
case you take the Knight there's rocktex
F2 Debbie amazing if you can't find
solve that wow Knight H5 is one of these
moves that are so difficult to find and
if he does find it shows that he is in
just top class form for this match The
Rook on f8 barrels down the f file to
the F2 pod the bishop and the queen team
up there and after Knight H5 you still
have to calculate a lot of things like
Rook to D1 but I'm guessing there might
be a queen sacrifice in the mix in some
of these positions uh as well it just
looks super complicated
he goes to 94 he did not find the move
all right so now what happens in case
origin just takes hey suppose she just
has to recapture the bishop but that
gives y time to defend the 985 is
hanging
uh he goes Knight F3 instead attacking
the queen also makes a lot of sense
where does the queen go maybe he has to
go to the three or I mean you could have
F6 white just takes here so perhaps John
missed a big opportunity there
and queen D3 Bishop slides back to C4
hitting the queen kicking it out of
there this suddenly looks very difficult
for black to play I could see black just
dropping a piece at some moment
yeah this could go wrong for for young
the good thing of him though is that
after Bishop C4 you can take and take an
F2 and take the bishop on or the queen
honestly foreign materials even in there
we have to move Queen D3 so what happens
after a move like Rook D1 though that
does feel like it's asking for trouble
but what exactly does black have there
Rook D1 I want to sack my queen somehow
is there Knight takes about this Knight
E2 Knight C1 one you take on D3 and then
you take an F7 that looks like that
looks like the way to go that's a great
thing
that's really cool that would be
unfortunate for
um for Arjun so he sees that but maybe
bring up the analysis for it because you
don't get to see a knight hopping around
like that so much so if instead of
Bishop to C4 we had a cool variation
where Knight takes C3 giving up the
queen but you forked the house first the
check then Knight C1 you win the rook
and the bishop out of seven is hanging
right uh but a fun Point that's horrific
system there's Knight G5 at the end so
apparently you had to flicking sticks of
three anyway let's get back to the game
so Bishop C4 was played the moves are
flying in young took on C4 we have Queen
takes Bishop takes F2 the materials even
and Robert as it often goes after all of
these fun complications we are in an end
game that is even
material and we see that four pawns two
Rooks and a minor piece for each side
I'm looking at the clock that is not
even 30 seconds maybe make it 40 seconds
Indian apology's favor but it's not
complicated enough for him to really
have huge winning chances
yeah I would slightly prefer to be black
here especially given the fact that
black is up on time but that being said
you know then I can always be a little
bit tricky 95 you cannot take the rook
and F2 as Rook d8 will be checkmates or
rookie rookie it very logical move by
John now perhaps origin if he wants to
sear the game into a draw he can go
another seven four by 96 so let's see
how he's how he's feeling
I would do that for sure 97 96 just swap
off the pieces I'm looking at the clock
situation the Knight where is it really
going to okay you guys Rook F7 similar
concept trade down to make a draw
yeah that's a tricky move though so I
guess in case it takes in kg8 you just
go 96 or Rook D7 Auto black can play
Move Like Bishop C6 and in case you take
then there's rookie two and then we have
a double edged game on our hands so
let's see how Jana's gonna deal with
this he takes on the the uh on a seven
and goes King G8
okay so Bishop C6 this is starting to
look
like white is gonna he pick up the pawn
A7 I think he might be playing the lose
versus playing the win because rookie 2
is going to hurt hitting G2 and B2 so I
would not want any part of that their
pawns on both sides of the board which
means the bishop is better than the
Knight and that's why he's chasing the
bishop around and after Bishop D5 now
Knight D6 I guess and you can't leave to
E2 because rook's hate his checkmate
exactly yeah so I don't know it feels
like practically perhaps origin is still
having a slight edge here after Rook d8
there's Knight of five taking the pawn
and G7 also you have all sorts of forks
then the pawn on A7 is hanging so nepos
still has to play a couple more Akron
moves here to save the draw so let's see
if origen can create some problems here
this is well done by origin it looked
like it should just be equals the eval
bars at zeros but that doesn't tell the
whole story now you see that black is in
a very passive position and it's clear
that white has the edge
yeah so Bishop he's like stopping that
if I put rookie seven nice move about
origin the bishop now has to move let's
say the D5 then you get Knight of five
and it looks unchartable he goes all the
way out to A2 I guess after Knight to
five you go Bishop F7 so it really
didn't matter where you put the bishop
but I'm somewhat surprised by this by
this move forward I guess though the
bishop can never be forked over here
that's the key is that it is so far away
from the Knight that you're not gonna
get to it and here Bishop F7 looks
completely reasonable but then what
Benjamin black is stuck after Bishop F7
you don't actually have a next move
no you don't I guess king of Fado is
there but why Musa Rook over to C7 so
let's say it's a bishop to seven you go
like king of two King f8 Rook C7 and Y
definitely has a small Edge there which
is not pleasant to defend against with
uh 30 seconds on your clock
when we're looking at the clock good
mentioned by you that Jan is now down on
time and his pieces feel stuck in the
mud he plays H6 okay what next I don't
see a winning plan for white but I might
play B4 A4 A5 just to advance my Pawn on
that flank and he starts with the King
side first to protect his Knight but oh
and look at Jan he made Luft for his
King so he wants to get active with his
Rook that's really great awareness
yeah rookie Gray movie on in case you
take an A7 black just goes Rook D1
followed by Rook D2 picking up the pawn
B4 but now Rook D3 forking both the A
and H pawns and this one should be even
Robert Yana has plenty of counter play
it should be and I think it goes to show
that RG played G4 a little bit too soon
he should have first brought his King up
potentially but either way Jan is
playing stubbornly great defense does
this a pawn or potentially A5 B8 B5 is
there some chance for white to
complicate this
there's still chances for white yet if
Arjun gets the chance he would love to
go 97 followed by Knight seat okay H5
yawn trading of the pawns he gives up
the the Jeep and the processor but I
think in case what he takes maybe
there's like Bishop D1 and I don't think
you can keep enough pawns on the board
wait Rook has three blood was nice
there should be a drop at RJ might have
defend rook and Bishop versus Rook
that's not very pleasant did you see RJ
he completely overlooked this and this
is how you win speeches Championship
matches if you're young upon XI is you
get a bit fortunate you have to make the
most of your chances but now the pawns
are coming off the board so it's likely
going to be rook and Bishop versus Rook
Benjamin do you think Arjun will be able
to hold that but how do you get that
Rook takes B6 I mean if you take with
the bishop now you're pinned so I don't
think you have a good way to get there
A6 but now can you see but you're just
pinned there's no way to get out or wait
there is wait there is
he's out now I think Arjun knows this
very well in Calcutta there were some
games where it was rook and Bishop
versus Rook uh this you make a mistake
at some moment the game is over that's
the big problem about this ending but he
uses the Cochran defense he wants to
keep his Rook pinning the bishop and
then he can bring his King to D1 this is
perfect technique
exactly the idea said in case Black Goes
Bishop C4 then you go Rook to D2 but
again Robert it's not easy with only
seven seconds on your clock so let's say
if yon can create some problems here if
we sit at the Eagle bar is showing the
draw the table base actually but it is
unpleasant to defend
no it's not but I know for a fact that
Arjun he is fully capable he knows how
to hold this he just did it recently so
I'm not worried especially as he builds
time on his clock
right so he again goes for that same
defense but then but now on the side of
the board so King here again now Bishop
Rook B4 hold to draw and uh yeah he's
showing perfect defensive technique
this is the hardest part is it's the
same defense
would have been an instant draw by the
way oh yeah he's so confident in his
technique that he's not even looking for
the forcing draws but it's rotating the
board is difficult in our heads right at
first you're pinning along uh the D file
that you're pinning along the fourth
rank things like that It's Tricky for
players to recognize but Arjun he's
doing everything right
yeah so now I guess he's going to go
rookie four and go King King here or
there so let's see right now it doesn't
seem like Jan is a very good way to okay
guess now Rook F4 is even possible but
he's feeling very wait wait wait what do
you do here wait Rook cheating wait
uh-oh this is a king with little time
there's it's easy to make a mistake and
a king of foreign check
and King runs to E1
would be oh my goodness okay he's in a
meeting that it looks like it's very
close here
this is insane Robert how is he holding
this one with four seconds on his clock
perfect technique the eval bar the table
base has not switched this game is going
to conclude in the draw and it does but
that was so close
that was incredible those incredible
defense by Arjun he was pushed with his
back against the wall he had a couple
sayings on his clock but he made all the
perfect moves and he he did not break
yeah bring the Rook to the E file there
that looks scary near the black king but
Arjun with the perfect execution of Rook
versus rook and Bishop defense now he
gets the black pieces it's still an even
match and banjo this might be our final
game of the five plus one
yeah so let's see here we have an
elephant by uh by John I wonder if he
also had prepared something like this
for the world championship match the
nice thing about the elephant is that
there's only so many variations you have
to know you don't have to worry about
the dragon the Knight of the sashinikov
you just have to know like the D5
variation and the Knight of six
variation and I guess there are some
Sidelines but you have a much better
idea as to what you can expect on the
board and I like what John has here he
has a slight initiative Rook the one is
coming a very easy piece play
right that Bishop on C1 can jump out to
a square like G5 uh this bishop on C5
can be kicked with Pawn to B4 at the
right moment so it does seem like white
has more plans than black does in this
initial position and so look at origin
playing H6 he's not committing to
anything just yet but look at how
quickly yawn plays in response
but so I wonder if Jana's still somehow
in his preparation I guess black has to
play Queen E4 offering the trade of
Queens Queen C6 as possible but it feels
like you're giving away too much of a
free hands and there we have at Queen E4
and Bishop B3 yon's still playing Super
quickly Robert what do you think do you
think he's still looked at this or is
this just young playing Super quickly
and confidently working his magic
I think he just made I don't know if
it's actually a mistake but if we just
go back a half move there if he took
with the pawn on E3 I thought that set
up some tricks with Rook takes D7 and
Knight takes B6 trying to steal a pawn
so there were I think possibilities here
for white to seize control because King
E7 would not have been possible but as
we see in the game on the other hand the
king is safely on E7 and White's Pawn
structure is not compromised so it was a
trade-off of getting quick activity or
hurting your own Pawn structure
you know I like that move Pawn xc3 I
think that was a that was a great move
Robert in these products C7 would have
caused Blackstone promise and now it
feels like the game is just completely
even I mean both sides have six pawns
there's a slight difference in Pawn
structure but neither side has any
weaknesses so it feels like like really
doesn't have much to worry about here
and you see Arjun trying to swap pieces
Jan says no but this B6 Pawn is
extremely well protected by both of
Black's Knights and I think black can
play Rook a to C8 how do you make any
sort of progress here if you're white
I don't know I don't see it perhaps
black can also make progress here in
moves like G5 H5 expanding a little bit
on the king side we have G6 a little bit
more reserved we see yanago and Rook D2
makes a lot of sense doubling up the
Rooks but I I think we'll see both sides
shuffling around a little bit here and
not coming up with a very useful plan
that being said or Robert look at the
clock yawn up nine what is it like
almost two minutes
the young has barely spent any time the
night just came out to C5 there
definitely are tactics in the air
whether it's an A4 Pawn uh going to be
captured there's Knight B3 then the
Knight on D4 has to stay put for that uh
it's hard to kick the Knight out of D4
of course but there's definitely feels
like there are going to be some tactics
that both sides need to keep an eye on
right and we see uh we see John just
moving The Rook back to the one all
right so now let's see what origin is
going to do to me to move G5 looks like
a nice move to improve the position a
little bit king of six also looks
completely fine
for both sides it's just difficult to to
make a move and improve right but that
is where uh you you just have to to make
one and keep up the pace
it's more difficult for white as you're
suggesting look at after king of six G5
is the move H5 is a move E5 is a move
and for white you're not playing B4 that
just hangs the C3 Pawn that would not be
good so he plays G3 a little quiet move
and for black he goes G5 maybe H5 maybe
he'll swing his Rook uh to the king side
at the right moment but I just like this
just a little bit more for origin
I guess he wants to go Knight to E5 H5
nice move by origin I'm starting to like
his position more and more he's got all
of these ideas like maybe H4 at the
right moment opening up the H1 or in
case of a trade then you carve out the
F4 square and if you carve for that four
square there's always going to be a jump
to D3 so it looks more accountable here
for origin and there we have the move H4
looks really Pleasant for black right
now I just think that you've gained so
much over the last few moves and white
has really just shuffled The Rook that
you want put a 95 but hasn't actually
created any threat so H4 is excellent
The Rook can slide to h8 at the right
moment here the black king will slide
back away from the check and watch out
for F5 at the right moment black
continues to gain space
exactly so let's see what John is going
to do maybe 95 check will receive
repetition there or will Arjun play for
the win with the move King G7 Jan can
also of course move out his Bishop at
any moment to C4 that being said moving
Bush to C4 does not look that appealing
to me as the bishop can always be
hanging so it's it's tough here for for
an apple to improve I don't I don't
really see a way he can he can make
progress here and I think Arjun
definitely has a slight Edge
and the time Advantage is almost gone
it's down to 20 seconds before it was a
minute 40. so Arjun doing very well to
to make good moves and keep Pace on the
clock and for Jan he's struggling to
find a single idea even if he played
Bishop C4 I don't know what the next
move is and Archen he goes back to F6 is
he willing to make a repetition
I think so the question is really
whether Jan is willing to do it or
perhaps
Arjun is just testing the waters he
repeats once and maybe now he's gonna
defeated move like King G6 or King G7 I
guess he must feel that his position is
slightly more pleasant young normally
would not go for repetition so I guess
he he must sense that there there might
be an opportunity here
but let's talk overall match strategy
and Arjun plays on he's always fighting
I was gonna say that isn't Arjun the
biggest favorite in the bullet so maybe
there's an argument to be made to drag
this game out if he feels like he
shouldn't lose to make this the final
five plus one game
that makes perfect sense so we see a
five year by uh by Arjun so the Knight
now has to move I guess you go to E3 and
after king of six maybe they're still
Knight C4 it all looks a little bit
loose for for y that being said Black's
position also is losing of the opponent
E6 is now a little bit tender the pawn
on F5 as well so this could become
double-edged and I think the nice thing
for yon is that now he's got clear
targets and I can go to C4 to defend the
rook and then you go Rook Au 1 and
opponent E6 wait what
he why not Knight C4 what what is this
maybe he thought the knight in C4 would
be able to be kicked out of there but he
gives it The Rook on E5 he wants to take
on B6 so Benjamin he'll get a pawn and a
knight for a rook he'll also have three
on one on the queen side but it's not
sufficient that's clear it's not
sufficient for full equality
yeah like I don't understand at all
Arjun just recaptures it feels like also
here black is a very healthy advantage
yeah maybe that was actually a smarter
reply from Arjun because the only weak
point in his position now is E6 he can
bring his Rook up to D6 to defend that
just another time because white is
threatening C4 or B4 to go after the
pawn and I think that Rook D6 is just a
smart move to keep everything together
yeah Rook D6 looks like a nice move
defending the pawn and again what is
White gonna do Jan does have the action
on the clock but the rook in E5 is a
little bit loose if you go to E3 there's
always going to be an F4 push to reckon
with so I love the position for origin
and the question also is how are you
gonna defend the pawn on A4 I guess for
the moment it's not a threat as A6 will
be hanging as well but perhaps the real
problem for why it would be rookie Chase
followed by a rook to h two but not
right away right because now B4 C4
creates counter play
yeah B4 Rook H2 check is just a single
check so can you bring his he does bring
his Knight back and we saw an exchange
sacrifice on offer once of course Jan
goes for it again and now we have a
position that's super interesting it is
a rook for a bishop and a pod but make
it two pawns because F5 and A6 they're
falling down too
and for sure and here yawn certainly has
compensation the knights Undertaker the
nine most B6 is hanging A6 as well and
here the clock Advantage is certainly a
factor as the position is heating up he
goes to E5 for this Knight all right so
I guess in case you take an A6 or
protective C3 and break black creates
counter play very quickly so he takes
Upon A B6 but now what does he want to
do is he going to go for a Perpetual
here
if I'm young I'm doing that because Rook
H2 check really bothers me I don't want
to see my king on the first rank so Jan
has the opportunity to keep checking the
king he's going for just that
all right and so this game ends in a
draw of Roberts we're gonna have one
more game in a five plus one portion
let's see who uh who will take that one
I think for Jan he's happy to play one
more game the longest time control and
he has played very nice chess throughout
he he feels probably some confidence by
gaining the lead on the clock and this
is now officially the final game of the
five plus one but Arjun he's mixed up
his opening this time he goes for an
English
yeah so we have this move 95 there was a
movie E4 as well but the players are
still playing Super quickly Robert this
is sometimes what impresses me that
players play very very quickly into
something that to me looks completely
random but apparently it might be some
sort of theory
yeah I don't pretend to know the theory
in all these lines but the players they
always do it's like oh I'm gonna play
some completely random move and then
yeah well I've studied this 18 moves
deep so maybe you should think better of
it next time look at this position why
is there a bishop on D6 a pawn should be
there but then Bishop's probably gonna
leap out to B4 with a check and black is
castled doesn't have good control the
center with pawns but does have a lead
in development
right I think black would love to have
that Bishop let's say on the E7 on the
other hand though he's got a nice
development with this Knight and his
Queen out already so let's see what
origin's gonna do here Bishop B2 is a
move but I can perhaps straight he goes
D5 all right so now maybe the move that
you mentioned Bishop before or you start
with the move 97 I think if I think if
young could go 97 Bishop C5 or Bishop B4
followed by D6 he has a very comfortable
game here
it will be comfortable for sure and so
white needs to be quick Bishop D3 just
developing and after Bishop B4 check I'm
wondering if you play King F1 because
that's doesn't make it easy for black to
play D6 as you A3 and B4 and quick
expansion I know I have to watch out for
E4 I'm seeing that Rook on A1 being
loose but the general point is that and
he goes for it the black Bishop is
actually not a good piece
yeah it's really shut out here you would
you want to go D6 but then your Bishop
could potentially get trapped white also
has it is to go H4 followed by Knight G5
threading the spawn over here there's
also Knight E4 and I don't know this is
right up arjun's Ellie but he doesn't
play it
but he might do it next
four is still a possibility with Knight
G5 to follow I don't think that black
can take it or maybe he'll go to D2 yeah
he's going to the E4 Square so he's
playing this strategically but his King
cannot castle that is a long-term
problem and as you're pointing out
Bishop takes E3 would be a blunder from
black even though at first it looks like
a good move
nice move by Young I like the fact that
he put the queen here as now why can no
longer go H4 you can also not really go
G3 as it allows this track over here so
94 attacking the bishop here I suppose
you go back to A7 there is the move D6
by wide but I mean I don't know like
take Stakes questions how do you get
this bishop into the game
that Bishop looks terrible I guess you
can play Bishop C5 back and then push
your b or d-pawn right after so it's one
of these situations where I think
strategically players are going to be
very concerned but he does bring his
Bishop out to C5 kicks that Knight out
of there and that Bishop actually the
let's go Bishop will be very strong for
black
yeah for sure so origen has a decision
to make here does he trade at this
bishop on C8 for the moment it's pretty
passive and also his King problems have
not been sold yet he goes 94 attacking
the bishop I guess you just defend it
would move like B6 or D6 to continue
their your development because also as
the bishop A7 wide it can just go back
but it really hinges oh whether Jan is
able to bring all his pieces into the
game I think if he can would have moved
like D6 followed by Bishop B6 or B6
Bishop B70 is a very good game as white
is really struggling to consolidate with
the king in a phone
and John left his chair he probably
wants to take a quick bathroom trip uh
but he is not seated right now you don't
usually see Jan spend this much time and
that's because he's not at his chair so
Arjun takes a lead on the clock you made
some great points there and it's going
to illustrate the fact that the white
King on castled can be in danger but
first Jan has to return and there he is
there's the two-time candidates winner
all right and he plays the move B6
defending the bishop on C5
all right so let's see what origin is
gonna do I think Jan would love to go F5
followed by E4 or F4 trying to break
open the king side and uh it's difficult
for Arjun I don't really see what he's
gonna do here so perhaps Johanna can
still take a lead here in a five plus
one portion
so it was important for Yan to make that
quick repetition in the previous game to
get this final five plus one game it
looks great for black if Knight takes
Bishop on C5 the B Pawn takes towards
the center White's dark Square Bishop is
a bad piece you don't have open
diagonals for it and black is the one
who controls Pawn breaks and I like to
say this the side who controls the pawn
breaks is off on the side with the
advantage black can play F5 maybe F4 at
the right moment and White's pawns seems
stuck in place and that all that said
maybe Rook B1 to play for B4 but I know
black will play A4 to stop me
right so let's see what origin's gonna
do there's no easy plans for him I mean
Bishop D2 black just goes F5 I guess you
traded maybe bishop C3 but it feels like
black has got all of these Palm pushes
E4 is their F4 is there Bishop B7 and
there's no easy way to resolve the
problem with the king I mean G3 is not
really a move F3 doesn't help much
either and yons moves just come in very
naturally
and so we see a swap on C5 the B file is
open and White's B3 Pawn is a long-term
weakness so Bishop B2 somehow given a
question mark looks very normal I think
black can just play D6 I don't think I
would play E4 just yet I'd be worried on
opening up that Bishop on B2
exactly I think you want to keep all of
the ideas on tap you just want to go D6
here followed by Bishop B7 then F4 at
the right moment or E4
it's it's not easy for why dealing with
all of these uh these spawn pushes and
like you said the pawn B3 is somewhat
tender so I think white should have gone
Bishop D2 to C3 same idea but just a
little bit more solid and John again
he's working his magic he's playing
quickly and confidently and putting the
pressure on Arjun in it's looking tough
at Forest coming E4 as well white
doesn't have any moves so as far as I
can see
I don't see any good ideas right now F4
looks very scary or E4 followed by F4 uh
you can't play G3 that opens up the
diagonal because H3 which I don't fully
know what it does and blacks moves the
follow-ups seem extremely easy
right to Roku 6 by yawn he's defending
the spawn on D6 the one drawback though
is that now you can no longer E4 as you
hang that broke over here so we see F3
by origin I guess he realizes that E4 is
no longer an option but I don't know it
all looks a little bit loose
E4 still looks kind of interesting but
he first brings his Rook to f8 and now
the White Queen goes after this is very
smart play from origin because if the
Queens come off then there's no attack
and that's why Yan brings the queen back
of course wants to keep the Queens on
the board it's looking very strong can
you one clever move by origin he perhaps
also walk his King out of the danger
with kingly to King C1 Queen E8 by Young
perhaps he's working at some A4 push so
let's see what what Arjun is going to do
here
A4 would be nice to hurt White's Pawn
structure and the King on E1 where is
that going maybe at some point you just
run Petrosian King march go to D2 go to
C2 and it's hard to actually Checkmate
the king over on the queen side
rookie won by Young a surprising move I
guess maybe he wants to go for E4 but
I'm not a big fan of e4s if I can just
go F4 I like this move much better
Knight C6 and I can go to B4 another
idea Robert is to go F4 potentially not
right now is that it would hang the rook
and after E4 you've carved out this
Square on D4 but right now John is
holding all of the trumps so let's see
if he can convert here
and the eval bar is going into Black's
favorite King D2 not recommended night
before and there's also D5 you want to
open up the entire board against that
white king and if you get D5 that Brook
on G6 may swing to B6 at the right
moment and here it comes
yeah D5 great move by Young opening up
this diagonal First bishop the record is
going to B6 also you can go Queen E6
putting massive pressure on upon B3
maybe origin has to go E4 here try to
uh create counter play as quickly as
possible in case it like takes maybe you
can take over here but there's Rook C6
wait robber maybe he has the second D5
and then take an E4
and that's something that Jan for sure
would do if he had the white pieces now
origin has to return the favor we saw
Jan do this a game ago sacrificing an
exchange for that initiative and Arjun
plays G4 and look at Yan he sacks The
Exchange on G6 gets the double X slam
who cares about this Rook a queen
landing on G6 will help deliver a
Checkmate whoa right right so now origin
sucks but it feels like it's not a very
well time now Jan just recaptures you
can think of G6 but like black takes to
Queen and I think now you just move your
knight back to B4 putting pressure on
the bishop in case you take over here I
think like is very close to winning I
mean he's just up a very clean exchange
why it's got weaknesses all over the
place and the pawn in G4 is hanging as
well Robert I don't see how Arjun is
giving this one together and he's got
eight seconds
and very smart play from Jan now there's
the diagonal against the white king
Knight to eight two check King has to go
to the default and Rook d8 check the
case of the E5 Queen B1 at the end that
looks like it pixel material but he
takes a Pawn on F3 because queasy to his
mate
yeah he does not want a free rookie once
or a sec to Rook himself Queen C4 by
origin but you're not holding this one
together Rook F2 you're threatening
Checkmate all over the place in
attitudes with her Rook C2 this is gonna
be one for y'all 93 is good enough as
well and we see yon taking the lead
going out of the five plus one portion
with a one point lead the five plus one
is over we had an hour and a half of
action John napamshi wins that final
game he currently leads by one point
over our generic I see five and a half
four and a half so Benjamin Justified
for Yan to go for that repetition and
get one final game in in the longest
high Patrol where let's face it the
classical chess high rated player is
usually the favorite the more times of
the clock
exactly yeah so John he seems to be
better at managing his time so the more
time there is there more there is to
manage so I guess that is why he has the
edge uh in the longer time controls we
see him always being up on the clock and
I think someone deservedly he's got the
lead here I think uh you know it's been
very up and down so far but I think it's
it's looking uh but as long as we're
young but Arjun still has his chances
for a comeback oh argent's right there
just one game behind because of that
loss there but the action is going to
get quicker it the players they'll have
to trust their intuition more and just
like quicker action you might want your
financial systems as fast and smart as
the 2023 speed Chess Championship
presented by coinbase and they can be
check out coinbase.com update the system
or use the command coinbase and chat to
learn more again the command is coinbase
in chat to learn more so you're on the
palm she leads by it one point right now
Arjun erag icy will get the break he'll
be able to review some of those opening
lines fix some of his weakness and
hopefully play quicker chess because
right now yawn has been too fast for him
this is the speed test Championship
presented by coinbase we'll be right
back for more from Yana palmchi versus
our generic icy after the break
[Music]
thank you
we're here in Toronto for the global
Championship I got Fabiana carwana with
me you don't need to talk yet I got
James we're gonna see who recognizes
these guys out of the out of the random
passerbys and we're gonna ask some some
fun questions about Chess for five bucks
do you know who this is
no okay an actor well you see this guy
any idea who he is somebody very famous
he is
this is actually 50 Cent's brother his
name is Daryl that's right it goes by
75. you want to play chess okay so what
is he a player or something or chess
he is a chess player I'm not but he is
yeah I play on the side yeah I've been
taking some coaching lessons from
Grandmaster Canty over here recently
over here calculation over everything
what's your name again sir uh my name is
Jamie what's your name
I already know any it's
Daniel yeah Daniel noradesky okay
there it is
on the attack baby on the attack if he
wins I know the guys at chess.com we'll
get him a diamond membership okay do you
know what that is yes okay is that
something you want yes yeah okay look at
you look is this a London yo we got a
pro here with the London
how'd it go
I should have said youtube.com
csq pod what is the URL this YouTube
actually don't remember okay
look at the pot
[Music]
become chessables next best-selling
author enter the 2023 create your own
course challenge and earn a shot at five
thousand dollars here's your chance to
bring that course in you to Life share
your passion for chess on an
international scale and bang while doing
it zero course creation experience no
problem Grand Master Maurice Ashley will
show you the contest mechanics then our
team will guide you through the
publishing process step by step like
we've done for over 250 authors and best
of all the winner will have their course
presented by Grandmaster Maurice Ashley
himself visit chessable.com create to
join
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the 2023 speeches
Championship presented by coinbase on
the screen in front of you is Arjun
aragi Arjun had quite the year last year
alongside his Junior speeches
Championship Victory he also won the
third Tata steel chess event in India it
was his third Victory he won the blitz
portion and in that three plus two time
Patrol he had two hot games against
Hikaru Nakamura so he was the 22-2 blitz
Champion India Benjamin we know you
don't win those tournaments by accident
no for sure he beat the car in both
those games he also tied with shocker
momijarov and he had an amazing run in
that tournament in 2022 really was his
breakthrough year he started off the
year very hot winning tadasil chess in
the Netherlands he broke 2700 so he's
really established himself amongst the
lead in in that year
now he's been phenomenal ever since me
he has been so strong he did have a
shaky start to this year in tata Steel
in the top group The Master section but
he has been able to right the ship in
fact he lost that nail biter to
prognananda in the World Cup if it
didn't come down to that final game
there where Prague was able to win maybe
it would have been Arjun who would have
been lifted by the Indian fans on his
return from a triumphant World Cup and
those two are very close friends by the
way Benjamin they were inseparable in
Kolkata
yeah I know for sure so we see Arjun
getting ready he's a point behind in the
match but I think he cannot be too
unhappy he still has a chance to to come
back so let's see how he will fare in
the three plus one portion Robert what
do you think do you think his chances
will improve a little bit or do you
think it's uh it's it's going to get
tougher from here
I think the quicker the time control the
better it is for Arjun he's such a fast
player he's very gifted tactician and I
think that young is building up these
huge leads because Arjun was spending
too much time and as we see liftoff in
the three plus one Benjamin I think
sometimes we actually kind of believe we
have more time than we actually do when
you're given five rather than three
minutes to start the game
exactly yeah and here we have the dragon
so let's see which line Jana's gonna go
for he goes for Queen side castles D5 we
see Knight takes C6 followed by Bishop
H6 all pretty uh pretty centered I guess
John has looked at this maybe for the
world championship and origen is already
thinking here
that's not a good sign because when you
play something as sharp as the dragon
you need to know every single variation
otherwise your king might just get
hunted and Jan has played instantly to
this point but finally he slows down or
not he throws his Pawn forward to E5
Benjamin I think we know what he wants
H4 H5 developed the rook in its starting
Square by going for a Checkmate attack
but what about this Robert after 97 what
if you go Rook to D4 without even go for
a very quick Rook H4 and how do you
actually defend against 97 are we gonna
we see the move H4 also a nice idea this
one also does not look easy for black to
defend against so in 1965 I guess is
forced H5 maybe there's Bishop F5 so
that in case you take there's Bishop
takes but Roberts what about this H5
Bishop five oh wait is this a line G4 F6
takes G5
is coming
no I think this is a line right F6
yeah he takes G5
now that would be a tragic blunder for
young that deserves two exclamation
points to point everybody is every
Bishop take is captured in F5 the black
one steps up to trap the queen in enemy
territory so that is why in the game we
just saw Yonder Pomsky drop his Queen
back towards E3 that was a necessity but
even here this still looks very
difficult for the black king
yeah so you take on G6 and now I mean in
case you take the Knight you're gonna
feel you're gonna face a fierce attacks
so Queen B6 I like the move by origin
trying to get the Queens off in this end
game looks pretty fine for black so I
wonder if this is still some sort of
series that both players are aware of or
if all of these moves were fine over the
board
and this moment here Queen the B6
forcing the queen trade because if you
keep the Queens on the board Queen takes
B2 check is of course going to hurt the
white king great awareness from Arjun
and even though temporarily white is up
a pawn White's remaining pawns are all
In Harm's Way the F3 Pawn the G4 pawn
and of course the H7 Pawn that one
probably is not going to be so long for
this board
yeah so let's see where arjun's going to
go you can go either to G7 or a trade
also F7 but really these two squares
make the most sense and then you're
going to pick a deployment Rook to h8 in
the meantime though yon can try to
create some problems with a move like
rookie one eyeing the pawn on E7 and we
know how good he is with developing a uh
an initiative
rookie wants a great move he instead
plays Bishop E2 just defending and now
he's going for the outside pass Pawn
this is where the engine can be
misleading for viewers where it's a zero
it's not a big deal but if the Rooks all
four of them get traded white might have
a winning end game with B4 A5 and so on
that outside pass Pawn is dangerous
yeah it goes King E2 moving his King to
the center first all right so let's see
what origin is going to do you could go
with D4 King G7 also very logical bring
his King to the middle Rook H1 Rook h8
is possible but I think he made a great
Point Robert it is strategically
dangerous to trade of all of the Rooks
white does have before afterwards A5 is
coming and it's not very obvious to me
how you're gonna stop that Palm
no Universe where I would play rookie h8
even though I want to compete for that
open file instead Arjun plays D4 kicking
this Knight and if the Knight goes up to
E4 and maybe the A4 Pawn becomes tender
with the C5 and potentially even C4 for
black you're fighting for some critical
space in the center
yeah so I like to move d4 you're going
to have to move the Knight here 94 looks
like the most logical and then you go to
C5 black has a lot of space in the
center and also you stop by from
expanding with moves like B4 so I think
Origins got it has done a good job here
and I I'm a little bit surprised as to
why Nepal was thinking is 94 to me look
like the only good Square
but that I think is what you want to do
is play the second move quickly he knew
Arjun would play C5 so he wanted to put
Arjun back on the clock and now that
Knight on G3 is it going to H5 with
check if the bishop goes to C6 which
looks very strong is their Knight F5
check or Bishop takes A4 that may be a
free Pawn but Knight F5 looked too risky
oh look at the eval bar it's because
these end games are difficult for black
because of White's outermost past Pawn
right and look at this Robert Jan could
consider Knight to five and there we go
black has to give their Bishop now you
trade and take and it this looks scary
for like if you go F4 King D3 to C4 to
B5 and in Pawn races the bishop is all
always so much better than the knights
so let's see how Jan is gonna create
some problems here maybe C3 also could
move like this position is always so
weak
oh my goodness he is displaying just
unbelievable technique right now first
doubling his own pawns getting into a
pure Bishop versus knight end game now
C3 he wants to take on D4 play B4 and A5
and if you take on C3 the king takes
back then white plays B4 and takes to
the king over there and then the B6 Pawn
will be hunted
right so let's see how Jana's going to
continue here B4 makes perfect sense
trying to get the king up or F4 kicking
the Knight away black and go Knight C6
and meet King C4 with Knight D4 but you
just move your Bishop to D3 and then B4
is coming to this launch that 994 so
this feels like a technical win for yawn
but Bishop D1 seems way too slow
what was that I don't even understand
the point of it Like Us in time here at
Knight C6 can you see 4K V7 this is just
a draw now you know what he did he saw
Knight C6 to D4 it was stopping the king
coming to B5 but I think he forgot that
Knight D4 is not force here and the
black king goes to D7 he just threw away
his entire advantage
must be upset about this one I mean yeah
it felt like he had this one in the back
he just had to make a couple more
accurate moves but now it feels like
Arjun is is holding the draw so let's
see though if if young can still create
some problems if anything you would
still prefer to be white here the bishop
is more active than the Knight and white
does still have some Palm breaks
and these two double pawns they may look
bad but it's not like black has a pass
pawn and they're all defended 92 they
Pawn you up to A5 and you just shatter
the defense is there oh in the queen
side the white king will pick up C5 then
go over and Hunt A5 but this should be a
liquidation Knight takes F4 and E6 next
yeah I just want to just had us for a
draw and I think so four king B5 and E6
this F Pawn is going to get traded off y
takes over here so that being said if
anyone can still win a spawn it's yawn
also origin getting along the clock but
I I'll be shocked if if this one does
not end in a draw
at this point it's
an easy easy draw
yep
all right but that was a shocker robber
let's pull that up real quick I mean
this game is going to end in a draw
apparently he should have played F4
followed by King C4 right away and I
think sometimes maybe you can even sag
the bishop and go for the a pawn
oh that would have been nice the a pawn
runs so quickly it was surprising that
Jan who typically goes full steam ahead
he went Bishop back to D1 I think he's
upset at himself still and he must have
looked at this in the break we saw this
line earlier today you don't repeat A
variation where you got checkmated in
the first 15 moves of the game unless
you have studied it
right but is Knight C6 the move so why
can a Gengar 95 you don't have King H7
because of 906 check I'm sure he has
looked at this otherwise this this would
be insane but let's see how this one is
going to continue so Knight D6 maybe
move like D6 and now we see origin is
the one thinking
but this happened yesterday between Ali
Reza and Wesley Knight Knight D5 D6 E6
was what was played and we are getting a
repeat of that Jan all these top players
they're frequently watching other
people's matches because they're
learning opening ideas they just want to
have some fun and watch high-level chess
and speech has time controls but in
general they do pick up opening ideas
from one another and so Jan you might
have learned from Wesley and now he's
fixed his decision making in the opening
right so E6 white is turning Checkmate
here with Queen E4 so now you have to
stop the king back there's no more
Knight of six check as this Pawn has
been pushed up and there we have the
king H7 so I think I've also seen a game
here recently it goes like Queen E4 King
G8 E7 Queen here Knight takes everything
gets traded off you take an A8 and
somehow it's it's a draw you know that's
often how it goes I don't know exactly
how but uh yeah I guess that is the line
we're going to go down and this is the
alireza Wesley game so this is look
we're seeing just that we're gonna see
Knight takes C7 and the White Knight
that's on A8 doesn't get out of the
corner nor does the Black Knight on H1
so somehow it gets to an equal position
where in that game white stole a pawn
but the computer didn't mind so much
right Bishop B3 by origin okay so he's
continuing his development is going to
go queenside castles mind you just for
the moment black is down a full Rook but
again the sound of each one is gonna get
trapped sooner or later
John thinking again again he but he does
come with the best move Bishop design I
think now is the time for why to take on
C7 we'll go down this end game but I
think with accurate play Black should
hold the draw
and the reason why 1967 is needed now is
if you Castle Queen side Blacklist Rook
C8 and stops all of that nonsense with
the Knight capturing the pawn and
winning The Rook so then black would be
up material white would still have his
past Pawn that's dangerous but I think
objectively black is holding on and
that's scary to play into something like
that from Arjun he knows better he is
going to swap queens and take that Rook
right so we're now in that end game king
of seven attacking the Knight I think
here you go Knight C7 Rook C8 we were
talking about the Knight of H1 that's
gonna get trapped but the Knight lc7 is
trapped now as well so take take I think
then you go Queen side castles and the
Knight is still trapped as this bishop
over here is still covering the square
enough too but one way or another black
manages to to hold the balance here I
don't know how to you you really have to
know what you're doing here
yes and King D2 yesterday we saw castle
queenside and here Arjun was King D2
that way there are no pins on the C file
uh and that's actually what happened
yesterday so this is a bit more precise
from Arjun he really knows openings
extremely deeply there's this famous
video of him from tots of Steel chess
India where he's talking to Vichy who
was commentating and vicious do you
actually know more of this lines yeah
here here here here here here it just
never stops with him
oh Robert look at this line 94 checks of
King E3 you take an F5 King dick C4 and
then I think a crucial move Rook takes
C2 if you take the Knight there's Rook
C4 and you're gonna get checkmated wow
that is incredible because it looks like
you just gave away a piece but yacht
steals the pawn C2 and if anyone's been
what oh
well and Jan's laughing
but how why did he take why did he take
like he was thinking young Blitz all of
this out what's he think that John just
blundered the Knight
oh my goodness look at Arjun aragaisy he
is beside himself usually Arjun you
can't read his emotions but he just
walked into Checkmate G6 is Unstoppable
wow wow wow and young takes a two-point
lead that was a big game for for young I
mean that's incredible I think all of
that might have been again some sort of
theory and I'm shocked that Arjun took
the night there I mean he didn't have to
he didn't have to you could just make
any other movie it would probably be a
draw I mean did he just think that Jan
blundered it's incredible
and we often say don't trust your
opponent but I think here he could have
trusted Johan that that piece was not
for free we are getting a repeat of this
earlier game oh and Rook E1 played by
Young the engine doesn't like it uh Camp
black just play moves like D4 and queen
A5 and things like that maybe not D4 yet
because the Knight goes to E4 and G5
quickly but something like that it feels
like white is in some trouble
this feels like it gives like way too
much of a free hand on a queen side I
mean Knight C5 followed by Queen five or
queen A5 right away I guess we know E6
has has to be played to create counter
play as quickly as possible but rookie
want to me looks way too slow I'm
surprised that young thought that this
is the way to go
what is this I mean he instead of having
an attack with H4 H5 he did give a pawn
in that game at least temporarily but
now he's gonna clean back to D2 it feels
like black has like three free turns and
now Knight C5
just played as soon as I brought it up
and uh this looks very dangerous for
white
yeah I'm really surprised by what yon is
doing here it's pretty interesting we
saw in the last game how he improved on
his opening in the petrol but here it
feels like he's
um he's uh worsened his opening by going
down this line with rookie one which
doesn't seem to be doing anything black
just has all the attack on the queen
side Bishop 5 is coming couldn't be
forced there at some point you can even
consider sacking The Rook and now you
understand but he goes now now it takes
B2 yeah because 94 check to follow
that looks great is he gonna go for it I
mean
there's no way Arjun will miss this it
is just brute force and I think yawn now
sees it the way he's looking at this
position like um uh oh what am I doing
here how do you win a game like that by
delivering a Checkmate and then
immediately walk into a mating attack
right I think that is that is yeah like
we've talked about this before before
the break we said that it feels like
Gianna's having the upper hand but it
feels like he's letting Arjun win games
too easily he had that game earlier in
the patch of where he lost right out of
the opening and the same thing here if
you're playing a match you're gonna have
to work hard to get to win games but if
you just throw the game after you all of
your hard work has been for nothing
because he's still gonna be up one point
that's the good news but he was up by
two and immediately let Arjen feel like
he's right back in this match When you
crush somebody especially as one of the
top players in the world like this you
start feeling really really good about
your chest and what is happening Rook B8
Rook B1 Queen takes A3 that's the mating
sequence but he goes Queen B2 to stop
Rook B8 at least for a move
yeah exactly and C5 gray move by origin
why would have loved to go Queen before
to offer Queen trade but now that is not
available you simply do not have a way
to get rid of this Knight on C3 and
black probably has all the Time in the
World to go let's say D4 maybe King G7
even to prepare Rook V8 but I can why
does not take with a check and then you
take here with Checkmate 94 Robert this
one is over the queen is under attack
you have to defend the Rook but if you
go here there's Queen C3 there's D4 and
there's Rook B8 origin's gonna come back
within the point and there we have it
I mean it's one of the easiest wins
you'll see at this high level and uh for
this match as you mentioned Benjamin
we've seen two absolutely horrific games
from Young where he just hands Arjun
extremely quick victories so Jan at his
Peak we've seen some great games from
him but then he also has the other side
of yan where he's lost in pretty much 20
moves in two different contests
yeah again it feels like he should be in
more control in in this match like I
think it's really been some some
unfortunate losses that to me seem quite
unnecessary uh so he just has to get rid
of those and then I think he's got a
really good shot at winning but right
now Arjun is very much in the match as
well so here we see in English with
black uh taking sort of a reversed close
Sicilian setup 92 by origin he wants to
go B5 and Target that pawn on B7
why not you use that Bishop on G2 to
your advantage and the queen goes to C8
both to protect B7 and Bishop H3 is an
idea trying to trade the fiancado bishop
so the last two games from both sides
have been bad because Arjun walked into
Checkmate right there and then Jan did
pretty much the same thing now we have a
positional battle do you think that
they're intentionally changing the
Dynamics of the position
I think so yeah I think origen realized
that it was 184 John has it covered with
the patch of Defense Arjun really wasn't
able to do anything there and so he
switches it up uh okay so Bishop H3 nice
move by yon I want to like he was
sacking a pawn with uh this move but in
case you take and take on C7 I guess 924
is way too dangerous for white so Arjun
just traded over here and this one to me
looks pretty fine for black right now
but there's no targets to exploit and we
see that the bishop on F6 is kind of an
awkward piece but we have just seen
white push to B6 and black push forward
to C5 so a couple more moves
are in there and this looks dangerous
for black because the D6 Pawn is loose
and the H6 Pawn is loose oof this is
odd Quincy six check of course that way
the decent spawn was defended tactically
right so E4 by origin to block it again
now Rook A6 the pawn on B6 can easily
become a weakness it goes Knight E5 but
now I think black can easily create
counter play on the king side with F5
coming so I I'm starting to like it for
young he's got the only open file on the
board of B6 Pawn feels like a weakness
and F5 is coming as well
looks really good I mean now that
White's Pawn structure is compromised F5
as you mentioned the King on G2 is in
much worse shape than the King on Jake
but he starts with H5 so it's clear that
when he does play F5 he's intake with a
piece which he probably won't do anyway
I love this for black
and at this retriever okay he's going
for more of a positional approach for
now he's holding back on that idea of F5
although he can still go for it why
can't take but then the pawn on D5 is
always going to be terribly weak so it's
looking great for Jana punishi so let's
see how he will uh how he will continue
from here again again I I feel like he's
really gonna try to avoid those
unnecessary losses because I think if
they play chess yon seems to be the
better player
he is higher Ridge in classical chess
Arjun still quite young he's improving
and he's improving his position after
the F4 going right after the black king
now white can take on E5 or even throw
in the move F5 at the right moment but
Benjamin look at this Rook F2 Rook F1
and the black king does not look very
safe
but what about this move Queen to G4
threatening Bishop takes H4 and how do
you defend against that maybe Queen D1 I
think you have to try to get the Queen's
off as quickly as possible
um otherwise there's going to be a
second H4
fantastic move Queen to G4 uh this looks
like a huge issue for the white king I
was just saying how the oh he walks into
Bishop takes H4
wait but what about this robber Rook
takes to be too full of a take C5
taking the rook and opponent G3 that
looks great for Yan
and Jan he looked aside I think he sees
it he's just making sure that it's
correct you double triple check but Rook
takes B2 then Bishop takes E5 hits
whatever captures on B2 and the G3 Pawn
at the same time black has a huge
Advantage right now
all right so let's see what we think
speed two I mean it's attacking the
queen you're you're gonna have to take
so let's say you take this row group
takes B2 sorry Bishop C5 maybe a rook F3
I guess you have to defend this Pawn
over here so Rook F3 to me looks forced
or I mean d foreign C4
but you're gonna love this move Rook F3
C4 for black because the queen can't
take on C4 as The Rook on B2 is loose
and D takes C4 unless Queen takes E4
after you take this Rook on B2 so you're
just loosening up White's defenses I
think C4 if you flick that in it should
lead to a big Advantage for black after
Rook F3 of course
I I like that one but it feels like
64 it might still be manageable
for wide maybe you have to move Queen F6
and never have to move Rook F3 he goes
for the most C4 Robert he might have
also had the idea to go G5 takes H4 but
we're going down that line I feel like
after it takes 6.64 is that Queen F6
check King H3 oh no way King is three
there's Checkmate never mind
so wait where does the king go just rock
walks back to G1 there and then you no
Queen Kings you one there's Queen you
want a queen to street but there might
be king H1 check worker form
he has to find queen of six
that's so difficult to spot because
you're actually walking your king into
what looks like a checkmating net but if
he doesn't like Queen F6 he's he's toast
he's toast takes a C4 rookie two is
coming
Gianna's up upon here
and he's got a great position rookie one
nah it's over rookie one
stop
oh
he just picks up the pawn this is brutal
yes two pawns ahead you can play Rook H1
check now and after Rook hitch of a
queen G1 maybe and just force the
everything off the board
yeah and there's only one check for
origin so great win here for yon who
again opens up a two-point lead
see when Gian is finding those tactics
which he has been throughout the match
he seems Unstoppable and then you say
the only person who can stop Yawn is
yawn himself and when he plays these
Clunkers losing out right under the
opening
right and again we see a French defense
yon repeating the same variation that he
played in the 501 portion I liked how it
worked out for him I think 97 is a good
move by origin I think in that game he
castled right away and Janos very
quickly with A4 and 93 here Knight G6 is
coming a little bit faster putting
pressure on the bishop ends upon A5 he
goes for A4 anyway and I guess his idea
is just to Sag this Pawn over here
because if you take you're gonna walk
into an unpleasant pin
but to your point it does look better
for black because the king can still go
in either direction so white can't just
play B4 here you give away a pawn that's
not good and then Bishop goes to E7 and
then at some point you decide do I
Castle Queen said or King side and then
you make white look out in both
directions
move A6 to none of these three all of a
sudden looks a little bit misplaced they
can no longer to be five it can go to C2
but what is it really doing over there
black can also just consider thinking
this part over here Play Bishop D6 after
neutralize the PIN followed by King side
castles and why is black not just up
upon the vertical position so I really
like what origin is done here has really
improved on his opening
and I feel like for what you can just
save that pawn E5 so rookie one makes
sense but Bishop E7 Blacks next few
moves seem very obvious and white is
struggling to keep everything together
black can throw in C4 it's a point and
whoa speaking of struggling Jan's
interconnect connection is struggling
his camera just went out his connection
is gone he needs to get that back
because this would be another game where
he's handing a point to Argent you can't
afford that in an SEC match
yeah let's hope he gets back quickly
maybe you can go like Bishop G3 followed
by four but like we said the moves are
looking very very natural here for
origin you can also goes C4 follow the
bishop C5 and kingside castles I like
his position but let's hope we can get
John back as quickly as possible because
this is tough even if he makes it in
time he now has a big time deficit
and we know how fast he is but when
you're down two minutes maybe even three
minutes if he comes back with like five
seconds left playing Arjun in this
position that will not be fun uh so no
Yana palmchi insight for now and
Benjamin these are the types of things
that can turn matches around
yeah this might upset Jan a little bit
it's certainly quite tilting if your
internet connection all of a sudden
fills you and he's down at 50 seconds
Robert I don't know if he's gonna make
it back in time I mean sometimes there
might just be an issue that is very
difficult to resolve so let's hope he
can make it back as nobody really wants
to see him lose this way even Arjun you
know no player really wants to win on
time in a you know honestly this
position looks pretty good for black so
he'd would rather win over the board and
if Jan is not back he will lose this
game on time but the next game will not
start they will give the player some
time to figure out the connection
because as you said no one wants to win
a match like this especially not our
generic guys he wants to beat John over
the board and he still has a good chance
of that whether he's down one point or
two he I believe is the stronger bullet
player so he always has that time Patrol
to look forward to
and Jan is down his last six seconds I
don't think he's going to make it back
and Robert it reminds me of that title
Tuesday last round he showed up like 40
seconds late and I thought to myself
that hey if he doesn't show up I I don't
mind you know I just win the title
Tuesday but yeah we see Arjun here
winning the game it's it's very
unfortunate yeah young lost his
connection and now it's back to one
point
unfortunate for Arjun but good news for
Arjun oh sorry at first for Jan excuse
me but good for Arjun I'm mixing up my
words as the players they are not going
to play their next game until Jan's
connection is restored but it is a one
point difference between these two
players we are going to go to a break
and when we return we hope that Jan's
connection is back with us so stay tuned
everybody more from the speeches
Championship presented by coinbase when
we return
[Music]
thank you
God it's the same thing every time why
did you on passant bro I swear to god
Amazon should be enforced all my friends
watching and this day is taking forever
play faster if I could move this Pawn
backwards it would basically be
Checkmate ah and draws are dumb
I should be able to flag him no matter
how many times I repeat moves 1400 years
and it's the same game every
time you know what it's time for some
updates I'm tired of this I'm I'm doing
it stalemate is now a win for the player
who gets stalemated you're welcome Eric
Rosen hey it's the Rosen trout pawns can
move backwards why is that and never not
been a rule pawns can move backwards now
every piece should be allowed to on
passant what it's not even possible how
ship it dunzo update enter
why is an ending there's just two kings
on the board what is this Purgatory this
is so awesome what we're doing here guys
we're changing chess why can't people
just move however they want whenever
they want
[Music]
four actually it's closed
pawns are weak no more pawns can promote
on the first move update take that world
I'm not sure I made the users as happy
as I thought I would maybe chess doesn't
need an update Financial systems do need
an update though coinbase is working on
just that re-envisioning an entirely new
Financial system that is decentralized
and fully transparent thank you coinbase
for sponsoring competitive chess and
making events like the speed Chess
Championship possible go to coinbase.com
update the system today to learn more
oh he's I was here I was I was lost oh
okay well hey hey let's go oh no I think
you should have just done that Chad I
got 14. we beat it let's go no 15 unreal
no first try eight in a row nine in a
row baby let's go
let's go I gotta oh cool I got a little
achievement thing I honestly really
enjoyed that that was really cool become
a chess.com Community streamer at
go.chess.com start streaming
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase and
welcome back to yon napomishi he still
leads this match by one point his
internet is back Benjamin hopefully he's
fixed that situation in its entirety
because he cannot afford another loss on
time due to disconnection
yeah those were really unfortunate laws
there for Yan he finally opened up a
two-point lead again but we see Arjun
makes it back into one point so really
it's anyone's match and yeah it was
really frustrating for young especially
to lose like that with the white pieces
so let's see what's going to happen in
the next game
well Jan he's such a strong player he
gets a loss with the white pieces there
by disconnect now he has to have the
black pieces and Arjun while it's
uncomfortable for him too because you
don't like winning games by disconnect
you want to win over the board but he'll
take any point that he can get
right and here we see a Catalan Arjun
going for a quick 95 against the bishop
B7 variation I'm sure Giannis looked at
this for the world championship but
there's so many lines to remember and
you know when he when he played the
world championship against ding I'm sure
that he did a lot of repeating before
every game and also even during the game
you can think for a couple minutes but
here that's not the case you have to
Blitz and we see origin still playing
very quickly
Arjun he knows his openings extremely
well and here with the white side he's
shattered Black's Pawn structure
although White's double A pawns don't
look too impressive uh the bishop on C1
that is the advantage for giving away a
pawn and the queen size of C8 so this is
a long theoretical line and Jan did
spend some time just making sure he knew
what he was doing
right so here origin can take the
problem with either the bishop or with
the queen but I guess black had some
quick activity with like Rook B8 maybe
C3 the right moment targeting the upon
E2 he goes Queen A5 first so I guess he
wants to improve his position Rook d8
attacking the pawn on D4 so let's see
what origin is going to do here this
this always is pretty interesting black
has got these extra pawns but they're
not the prettiest
no and this Pawn D4 it can be threatened
at some point with a C5 if you can get
that to work but the bishop on G2 stops
that from happening as is the queen on
A5 so essentially white has this clamp
on the C5 and E5 squares now it's time
to I was gonna say develop the dark
Square Bishop he goes E4 the engine
doesn't react he knows these positions
very well that's clear
yeah E4 nice mobile origin stopping 95
stopping rookie five and making sure
this one is no longer hanging so that C3
doesn't really come with any effect
Bishop Rook B6 with Bishop A3 nice move
by origin we see that Giannis upper Palm
but look at this piece the 26 is
completely stuck the rook and B6 the
queen on B7 all of it feels very very
clumsy I don't really see an active plan
here for black and in the meantime
Vikings slowly but surely start to
improve their position so I like this
opening for origin
I love it and if I would look at this
from Beyond The Palms position I'd
rather throw some of my pieces off the
board if I could but that's not going to
happen especially if the bishop gets up
to C5 it feels like black is struggling
to breathe that Bishop on A6 is such a
poor piece what ideas come to mind for
Jan here
I don't know I don't see it uh I think
anything you I was just about to say
maybe C5 actually I like this move
because in case you think of the bishop
you can take an E4 you will have the
second exchange though after Queen E3 if
your knight is hanging The Rook as well
you go F5 y can take but you get a lot
of pass pawns on the queen side so maybe
from a practical standpoint this makes
sense bear with me could we see a queen
sacrifice would that be possible I guess
probably not it's not sufficient but
after Bishop takes C5 90 for Queen three
can I go Knight takes C5 uh probably not
because you can play D takes C5 that's
important to point out
right but can blight no black history
takes D1 would check on Rook B1 after so
even if that is still possible
surprised though by the move Rook B2 now
he's just given up a pawn and it's white
should have a very clean edge here
is the point that after Bishop A3 he'll
go Rook E2 and just try to survive on
the second Rank and go after the E4 Pawn
he clearly wanted to be active rather
than passive but look at origin go
hitting the Rook on deep and Bishop
takes F6 that opens up the black king
right but it shouldn't be too big of an
issue I would think Rook D7 by yawn in
case it takes takes a black product can
create counter play quickly with Queen
B4 maybe pushing the pawn down but the
queen could also swing back to the
defense so I don't know I think Bishop
B7 perhaps was a bit of a Miss by origin
I don't really see what it's doing here
and I don't think you have to be too
worried about this trade
and Jan is not where the evil bar
unconcerned itself and it says that in
fact black is completely fine and I
think a very important point is what you
mentioned E5 is meant by Queen B4
because if white could play E5 and take
on F6 white would have a huge attack but
with a queen trade on tap that would not
have been possible
right so we say queen of three but
origin of technopolitan F6 so if you go
King G7 here I guess the checks are
going to be annoying E5 will always come
with a Tempo so maybe yawn just has to
give up that pawn why can they can have
six but you go C3 very quickly you hit
the ball on D4 C2 is coming and it feels
like black should have sufficient
counter play White
cannot really create any threads on on
the king side it feels like
this kind of reminds me of the game
where Arjun was black against Yan where
his King went up to D60 those Triple C
pawns you know that's the counter play
you need is to distract White's voices
he played F5 and the engine doesn't like
it Argus has definitely no Queen trade
available for you and the H6 Pawn is
loose I think it's easier to play this
from the white side
yeah for a nice move but origin with
Queen B6 excellent stepping out of this
diagonal putting some pressure on the
pawn on D4 and defending the pawn on H6
so let's see what Arden is going to do
here he takes on a five can you take on
D4 it feels like there's got to be some
sort of tactic or Bishop D5 and how do
you defend F7
you can't The Rook on D4 needs the
Queen's defensive to go Rook takes D1
Rook takes D1 you still can't defend F7
because you don't have Queen G6 the F7
Pawn is pinned so that would be a free
Queen for white
right so what does John do here I guess
he has to go with his Roku to Bishop but
besides being done in exchange there his
King is also extremely weak Rook the
eight is there Queen G4 is there this
has to be a win for Arjun and Robert
this must be tilting for yawn he went up
two points in the match he loses one
game by disconnect and now he's losing
one game very quickly
and it's completely lost right now it's
a force situation Rook gate can you
check Queen E5 check if you have a queen
F6 there's Rook G8 a very important move
kicking that Queen the king away from
the Queen's protection oh goodness never
play F6
yeah he goes up six but this has to be
Checkmate I mean Rook D7 King up Queen
E7 first there's got to be a mate here I
don't see it right away though and keep
in mind that black is also starting to
Checkmate over here so you cannot make a
silent move but there's got to be
something here for Archer Queen D7
where's that black king going
I guess that that's got to be the way
and then check over here
G4S is game over Queen H7 okay King E5
keep running if Yonder Palm she somehow
goes King E5 King D4 King C5 King B4
King A3 and survives this game that
would be absurd
but rookie one looks like a nice move
but origin okay but the king is still
running away and his clock is ticking
we check
and check yeah no I mean if you're if
you go King here there's rookie six and
at least you lose the queen and king C4
is made so this looks uh this looks over
rookie six
yeah getting the queen that should do
the trick uh oh he didn't even take the
queen you want C6 to deliver checkmate
with rookie seven
all right so great win by origin and now
all of a sudden the score is even Robert
yes so we have a tied match eight to
eight so now I'm gonna get the chat
involved once again it's a tied match
who do you think is going to win this
one smarter chess predicted a win for
young the Palm she but a close match but
he also predicted that young would get
ahead in the Blitz and that has not
happened just yet
but did I predict that yellow was going
to lose by discount I think that's where
it um the mind of that it might not have
affected in that one and I like this
opening here by origin he gets the
bishop to the long diagonal and
generally black should be completely
fine actually 95 is a very important
move attacking the queen so that Knight
C6 is not a move after uh you move the
Rook right in other words that would
have forked and won some materials to 95
it's an opening in that's known to the
players it still is worthy of that
exclamation point because it is the only
move to keep black even but these
positions are tricky I think Benjamin
when you know a position as you know
Grandmasters we studied these games but
you don't get to see it very often you
can easily forget what you're supposed
to do
wow and look at this bishop D7 double X
Clem he does not move the rookie just
sex it because in case I would have
taken you recapture and actually there's
no good Square for the Knight so young
just moves his night back but now he's
just lost a lot of Tempe and Arjun has a
very comfortable position
just slide that Rook out of the oh no he
says you can have that Rook he's going
Alpha zero Style
wow he just put he's just pushing the H
button on the board Jan does not care he
does not want to take the Rook I think
Robert we're just gonna see a game of
ketamas here arjun's gonna play Bishop
B7 and keep hanging the rook and Jana's
probably gonna play a move like Bish
before not take yeah and there we have
it
and as long as black doesn't Castle
you can't take that Rook on a but if
black makes the mistake of castling then
I take your Rook because you don't have
a checkmating attack
but Robert look at this all of a sudden
I actually like the fact uh that the H
files opened up for white because then I
go King G2 followed by Rook H1 and where
does this black king go even if you
Castle White is more likely to launch
some sort of attack here and if you
don't I mean what do you do do you go
like rockef looks pretty clumsy I think
that perhaps RJ made a mistake by
playing Rook C8 he should have played E5
because kg2 would not have been possible
if that Palmer on E5 they were in Bishop
H3 check idea so isn't it park is King
in the center it looks like he doesn't
mind Rook AJ check his King can simply
slide up to either e or D7 and there's
no attack so he claims
it's a 94 interesting move by nepo after
a trade the defile will open up and with
this Rook sliding over to h8 that that
might be problematic for Argent so we
see this trade F6 okay I guess you moved
the bishop Arjun now getting a little
bit more room for his King but wow E5 I
did not see that one coming so Bishop
takes E5 this queen G6 check and that is
huge trouble because the Rook at C8 is
loose if you try to block with your
queen on F7 Rook HH check skewers and
wins that Rook on C8 so you can't take
with a bishop on E5 he first takes an F3
how does this work good check okay so
check maybe you can go like E7 in case
it takes there's King D6 and you still
wiggle out of it but I don't know wait
check wait check King C6 Queen E4 looks
deadly
King B5 and then
there's no chance
B3 B3 maybe it's running Checkmate over
here looking at six you check on Rook D7
but Rook D1 you can play Bishop D4 I
think that's the obvious reply both
overlooked that you just clogged the D
file but yeah the king also could
consider running and probably will run
after Queen takes G7 check
all right so Bishop D4 a nice move by
origin I guess now Bishop B3 putting
pressure on the bishop and you can still
take on G7 whenever you you want to so
young definitely still on the driver's
seat here he's got the safer King I
think especially in the Blitz game this
is going to be so difficult to play for
origin
oh his pawns are all hanging there's a
G7 Pawn because D4 is hanging now even
finding a move at this moment E5 looks
bad because the queen takes G7 check
um he plays it and the engine doesn't
really budge so Queen G7 King E6 and you
protect this F6 Pawn
yeah you have to go King six if you hang
this pawn it feels like White's doing
very well but then check and the attack
continues yawn we know how dangerous he
is in these positions he's got the
initiative he's putting pressure on his
opponents and and that's where he's the
scariest so let's see how he will do it
well he can also take on D4 first but I
think it makes sense to take on G7 for
now and and keep your options open at
some in some positions you actually want
to keep the bishop on the board that's
true because the bishop on D4 isn't
doing all that much it was B4 opening
another Avenue after bc5 bc5 at the
right moment The Rook can come to B1 and
maybe there are threats on both flanks
so B4 I think that if I were black I'd
be running with my king he runs in the
center he runs into the fire he does not
care Arjun era guys he says I'm up a
pawn
yeah I don't know I'm a little bit
surprised by Yonder I think he really
should have taken the G7 Pawn the king
86 for the moment is sitting pretty safe
there's limited material on the board
there's queen of seven coming queen D7
potentially and it's gonna be difficult
for Jan to really create some sort of
attack he's only got this rook and a
queen and Bishop but for the moment
origin is keeping everything together
and another annoying thing is let's say
you play Queen F7 Queen G4 F5 Queen H3
you don't really see fully how to get
your king safe and look at Jan's Rook it
goes up the a file watch out for Rook A6
check though if you go Rook B6 to block
Queen E8 check and it's scary for the
black king
maybe you have to go like Rook 8 or Rook
B2 also possible to go for your own
counter play I think that's and there we
have it I was just gonna say that's
right of Origins alley we have reptix A5
Rook D2 Rook A6 check is your king going
to D5
I guess so check King C4 I don't see why
not oh my gosh that King is just running
up the board and actually the checks run
out so white could just be lost there if
you don't find a forced draw because the
engines you see off the side the Evo Bar
says zeros it means young must have
something but it doesn't seem clear
but he goes for a Vertex 506 D2 okay
check okay so now you have to go King F5
I guess King D5 there's Queen G8
followed by Rook a six a king of five I
think that is fine for black right then
maybe white just has to make a draw
what an incredible drawing sequence that
is and I think you're right that uh
there's G5 but then I think there's uh
whoa what he plays on for mate
okay but where's the mate 20 seconds for
origin okay so check
three this looks extremely scary for
black
only move King for only move
you can check either way Rook F4 now if
you're gonna lose the Rook anyway at
least get another Pawn for it he goes
for it okay so take Stakes okay he goes
kingy Queen E2 king of Fight King D5
okay take the Rook you have to take it
okay don't take a screen he's six he
gives a check but now you can take this
there's no more 26. oh that's really
important oh Queen F3 and that's the
game 24 Rook D6 Rook D6 oh which wins
the queen
what a game what a game Robert right wow
it seemed it was going origin's way he
blunders check or he punishes Queen and
he looks so disappointed by that finish
there because John the palmshi once
again takes the lead but he played
amazing defense Benjamin that's the
second game that I can remember where
Black's King went on a run but RJ just
didn't have enough time to continue the
defense in his time trouble
right that that one is quite reminiscent
of that game we saw earlier in the
French defense where origin objectively
he was doing well he had a lot of Pawns
but with the time pressure and the weak
King position combined it's very
difficult and yon created some problems
and he wasn't quite able to figure it
all out so yeah a very important win
here for Yan who now takes the lead
again
and we get this position that we see in
front of us the dark Square Bishops have
been traded White Castle Queen side yes
played the pawn to C4 it looks like very
risky chess from Arjun and that's very
much his style
yes we say B5 by by Young he does not
care about the spawners who will give
him the Open Air Force Rook so I think a
nice sacrifice and I think origen just
has to ignore what John is doing over
here on on the queen side in case black
takes you just recapture the bishop
nothing really has been done on the
queen side so now maybe you just keep
pushing with like G5 and H4 is there
Knight takes E4 about to happen I would
be so scared about some kind of tactic
there but maybe there isn't because
white has enough pieces to defend the
attack Knight
right yeah I don't really see it
happening but it takes six night before
maybe it could be a possibility but I
guess you still go 92 and G5 has been
played but you know it definitely was
worth consideration he goes Knight D7
also very logical then I can swing back
to C5
in the meantime though Robert what does
black really achieves I mean B5 in case
you take your special takes and I feel
like White's play on the king side is
going to be a lot more straightforward
H4 H5 maybe H6 or G6 but it goes King B1
and I don't like the one as now a
potential Bishop takes E4 will always go
into check
an essential point that the king will be
in the fire of the bishop and now for
black there are all sorts of moves that
look very good you can oh he takes now
oh his King is so open
well it looks very risky but Queen E7
apparently was a Miss by Young maybe he
had some like Knight before action and
again going after the pony for he goes
27 Rook B8 feels a little bit slow but
Robert look at the clock yawn up more
than a minute
he's using time as his biggest weapon
the evil bars is white is better but how
do you play a position like this where
the Rooks are staring at the white king
so that Knight on D4 will likely go to
F5 that would be very threatening with
the queen D4 to follow but it looks like
Black's attack is much more natural
exactly so let's see what John's gonna
do he could go Bishop D7 sort of in case
y equals neither five you can always
chop the Knight off you can also go
Bishop B7 he does go for Bishop D7 I
like this one to keep the B the b and a
files open for your Rooks the question
though is like how are you gonna build
on your attack maybe something like
Knight A4 hitting the pawn you can
follow with C5 and it looks difficult
for origin and Robert we see this we see
this once again nepo down a couple pawns
but he's got the initiative
he loves positions like this but D3 is a
great move because black can try to
double on the a file white will just
then go defend the A2 pawns a queen E8
I'm not entirely sure what the threat is
but Knight F5 will never come with a
Tempo and that's probably very important
Robert I think this idea well I think
his idea was going to be to go Queen C8
to A6 but he goes Bishop to E6 a little
bit surprising to me now maybe he's
setting up some oh wait he wants to
Queen A4 uh-huh I guess that's that's
his idea so Queenie it was a sneaky move
it just looked random but he's trying to
go for the queen A4 now
yeah and how do you defend I mean queen
B2 there might even be Knight to D3 or
that's nasty oh
that's game and how do you do I don't
see a move Queen C2 you hang this you
hang this this one's over Robert it is
look at Yan he's stretching because he
knows he's about to take this game and a
two point lead and for Jan he had a
two-point lead earlier uh then he lost
the game by disconnect then Arjun was
able to win a game after that but if you
can go up to oh look at the queen on A1
What a Sad piece
right but it's holding the position
together for now young knows he has to
be winning here I guess you just take
the rook and then maybe move to Queen to
like A6 to try to slide into D3 he's
winning here but you know these these
players are tricky you still have to
finish it off but I I have full faith in
young that he will
it just looks so miserable for Arjun
here and look at the clock Giana spent a
ton of time on this move and he still is
ahead by a minute and 20 seconds and
Bishop takes H3
I'm a little bit surprised by that one
why not just take the extra material and
and play on from there why take this
Pawn on H3 right I didn't even notice
that there was a pawn over there but
he's taking all the parts a four okay
I don't know Robert I mean maybe takes
an hey Knight of five it's not an option
right now but it might be in the future
five
wait a second okay
how do you deal with this
you've got an id6 though you're hitting
the bishop on H3 but you get the Knight
on D4 back that still looks pretty fine
but I don't know it I don't like what
he's done I think he should just take in
The Rook
yeah that does gives white some play on
the king side as well if you take the
bishop on H3 get a quick Rook H1 I think
you don't have time to do that but if
you just slow down for even a second
that's going to be dangerous against the
black king
right so Jan has taken on the four six
seconds for origin this is looking tough
Knight takes B3 my wait can you go for a
1963 Knight takes this broken H3 is
offending this though
oh wait a second oh Robert Robert what
about this takes takes Queen E4 and then
you go like Queen G2 and then you take
as if you take the rookie you take the
rook in H1
that is an incredible line and I think
that White's still have very good
chances to hold because I think at best
black takes a queen but white has two
Rooks and an outside pass Pawn so there
will be chances but that is really truly
an unbelievable variation so if Jana
Pomchi plays it we'll get to see it on
the board and if he doesn't which it's
not gonna happen anymore he might lose
the game
wow now it's all even the King has run
out to E7 materials even black skin is
also pretty weak over here rookie won a
threatening Queen C7 what a throw by
yawn
he took a Pawn on H3 like that pawn was
on nobody's radar and suddenly origin
with 3.7 seconds left he has some ideas
of his own D6 is a target he played D5
thank you very much for that pawn and if
you can trade off some pawns here and
pieces I don't see why White's losing
yeah Queen H4 attacking The Rook Rook D1
okay the knights get traded off white
should be completely fine here uh both
sides have a queen and of which king is
weaker I'd still say maybe the White
Queen uh the white king
yes but look at RG just going back and
forth Queen D7 Queen to D3 and here
comes the Jeep on he's trying to force
the Queens up but that could be a
mistake because Black's pawns might be
easier to push
right in Queen C4 now young can trade
and white no longer has connected
pastors so Queen C2 yon wants to keep
the Queens on the board but Arjun keeps
insisting like hey I want to trade
I think it's a good thing for Jan to do
it makes arjun's moves more difficult to
play oh don't take it would be fine he
does a check
that would be to me
oh so what do you what do you do here
what do you do oh this looks scary
lights very pissed B6 B7 B8 is just
three squares away and Jan is about to
get down to 10 seconds is Queen G5
Rook B5 okay there's no Rook d8 Queen T4
nice move maybe okay four a four way The
Rook is no squares rookies two that is
incredible Arjun finds it The Rook acid
leave and the beep on Queens
that's it that's it the B Pawn you can
even give up the or King A1 and you're
gonna get a new Queen
what a game Robert what a game and look
at this there's gonna be an extra Queen
for white and a Checkmate Jana palmsee
did not put origin air guys away when he
had the chance and Arjun this is one of
the most incredible comebacks in a game
that you could possibly see
what a shocker I think again he should
have just taken anyone take the extra
material then play on but instead he
took the pawn on H3 and Arjun hung in
there and uh he got that other
opportunity to go Knight takes B3 but he
he failed to put Arjun away and uh yeah
what a comeback
and now we have an even match I spoke
too soon when I said young would lead by
two Arjun says not so fast we now have a
position where black is pushing this
Rook Pawn on the queen side but white
has this lovely Bishop on G2 so in your
experience Benjamin do you like this
from the white side or do you think
black's okay
I like it's from the Whitetail white has
this open Bishop as you mentioned and
actually this looks quite familiar to
the world championship match between
John and Magnus what was that famous
game where yon trapped his own Bishop on
on B7 so I think White's got a slight
edge here you probably move the Knight
out of the way you go D4 you have more
space and especially is feeling a bit
passive it looks like a Scandinavian and
I don't know if John Bartholomew is
watching but whenever you talk about
team scandi you have to give him a shout
out it does look like a bad Bishop on C8
for Arjun but where are the targets wait
you you mean note bad pieces and you
have to prove that you can get some kind
of Winning Edge where does white strike
that is always a difficult thing yeah
white is better he has more space the
more active pieces but black is
extremely solid for the moment he has no
weaknesses Bishop Y8 is looking pretty
firework to C8 the opponent A4 is a
little bit of a Target but you don't
really have a way to increase the
pressure so I think what you do is you
just continue improving your pieces with
moves like Rook if you want and you just
don't argue like hey what do you do
actually what is your active plan
he's gonna plant that Knight on D5
that's what he's gonna go for after
pushing that c Pawn away and I think
that it's very very solid here for black
as we see the position where is White
strike I feel like black has done
everything correct
yeah it looks it looks good for uh for
white uh White has more more space now
the bish18 is extremely passive the
policy 6 is the target 93. let's see how
Jan will tighten the screws here Bishop
6 origin hang in there but Robert it's a
little bit concerning it feels again
like Yawn is in control of this match
but the score is even and we see that
the origin is better in these time
scrambles so I really feel like Jan
should try to take a lead in in the
blitz portion with like you know a point
point or two but if for now he's not
managing to do so
this position is one where we keep
talking about where is the Breakthrough
Jan would like to use his space
Advantage black has this Pawn slash
Bishop on D7 maybe later will be a true
Bishop but for now it's just a pawn but
the D4 Pawn is also one that you need to
keep an eye out for in the long term
I really love these positions because I
feel like there's a lot of shuffling but
then I miss a way to break through and
then I regret not paying more attention
exactly yeah so we see the trade on B4 I
Think We're Young eventually wants to do
is maybe push her this Pawn to H5 or go
Bishop B1 right away followed by Queen
C2 Auto if you go Queen C2 right now
black and still go G6 so maybe now is a
good time to go H4 and I guess that's
why Arjun played queen of Fate to be
able to go G6 is now the pawn is no
longer hanging
and G6 then Queen G7 you can also defend
your king with your Queen's help and
stare at the D4 Pawn Center but Rook F3
as your indicate maybe there will be an
exchange sack at the right moment on F6
but you need to take care of the D6 Pawn
First D4 Pawn excuse me
all right so rookie four by yawn makes a
lot of sense I think he wants to go Rook
F3 and find the spawn so that's why RJ
now goes Rook beat a d8 putting more
pressure on upon Queen C2 by yawn he
still has these two Rooks in a way but
if he can somehow uh move them then he
is starting to check into Bishop B2 he's
switching his attention to this diagonal
but Robbers for the moment everything is
still looking extremely solid for black
and Bishop takes D5 Rook takes D5 to
follow how much does that actually hurt
black it's a closed position so Rooks
aren't shining as much as they can but
Rook F4 and now you have to watch out
Bishop takes E6 becomes a threat
doubling Brooks in the f file uh there
are gonna be all sorts of tactics in the
air
this looks nasty for black can you go
Queen G7 if you can't okay ghost Bishop
G5 but not Rook F3 D5 circuline option
or H4 Bishop takes E6 is a threat he
goes Queen Nissan but after H4 can you
still go to F6 or is there going to be a
sec young goesford wow yes he's in a
connected past Pawn on D6 that black
cannot challenge those Rooks that you
have two of them they're not really
Rooks it's a closed position in front of
them this looks terrible for black
and what about this move Queen E2
putting pressure on the planet E6 and
there's also Rook F3 the pawn and F6 is
super weak this is a great game by Young
it's a master class we kept asking how
do you break through how do you break
through he was continuing to post
problems he sacrificed some material but
it's not about peace quantity look at
the quality of White's pieces and those
Rooks are terrible they're just passive
oh no moves for black
when things before there goes Apollo but
now maybe Queen E3 hitting the spawn
over here if you take the pawn it's
going to be Checkmate it feels like Jan
is slowly but surely picking black apart
Rook at four nice move the queen has to
go to A5 and then you're just gonna
strike on this board like H5 or Bishop
B1 first
all of the above white has
all the choices black can barely do
anything this is the most besides this
early wins where Jan lost in like 15 to
20 moves uh this feels like the most
one-sided game where a side earned it
where they played better than their
opponent this is brutal H5 oh my gosh
Rook takes F7 to follow
origin origin still hanging The Rook F6
young tightening the screws he has to
put this one away he has a dominant
position and origen just resigns I mean
it's a terrible position but Robert
maybe he should have just played on get
some time off the three plus one clock
and hey we saw that in the last game
John also did did the throwaway to win
it's hard for a player to look at that
position any longer than you have to so
I get why Arjun resigned but your point
is a good one that when you think of the
overall match the gamesmanship that now
they're down under six minutes but if he
has spent a bit more time just wasting
some mesh clock he would have ensured
that this would be the final game in the
three plus one but maybe Arjun feels at
home in this time which really is even
at least on the scoreboard granted one
of those wins was by disconnect but RJ
he's used to this time Patrol in the all
the SEC formats and title Tuesday and we
have a fun variation right here in front
of us
right so we see the ongoing Knight bd7
it's sacking the pawn on D4 but in case
you think there is the movie E5 forking
the bishop and the Knight on D4 so okay
origin does stay okay so let's see so E5
now is going to be played the Knight has
to move to b37 in case the bishop you
can take the bishop on C5 so young
therefore decide to take on F2 and I
guess now you go Bishop G5 or you can
actually also take over Robert whatever
this bishop takes E5 Bishop B3 King B1
and can you sack the queen you get a
rook for a rock ambition for a queen and
a pawn but white is completely tied up
for the moment I love that variation I'm
happy to sacrifice other people's Queens
uh Jan not maybe as convinced as we are
but that looks like a lot of fun wow
what is it so what's the material right
now black is even I thought black was
ever Pawn but the E3 Pawn is a target
with Knight G4 to come but the D5 square
is White's for the taking the Knight on
B3 is loose right now not easy decisions
yeah so I guess you have to move the
Knight and there we go 92 Knight G4 now
looks like a nice move attacking the
queen and the pawn E3
and I guess you just have to give up
that pawn Knight C5 by yawn also a nice
move B4 variable move by origin he's
weakening his Queen side but he's
kicking the Knight away from the active
C5 square and hey Robert what about this
move H4 to create some counter play
yeah that's the capital has to be faster
so the eval bar in Black's favorite and
speaking of fast we have the penguin GM
in the chat rooting for Yan and Jan
unfortunately has not heard his uh
supporting message because look at this
H4 trying to rip open the king side
Benjamin this looks really dangerous for
black
yeah I assume you have to go to G4 but
maybe white just goes to H5 followed by
H6 Robert I think Jan should have played
the move Knight takes C5 for your second
night because it feels like you get a
very dangerous attack on this Nana C3
Bishop B6 is coming Rook a seat but
perhaps he played a little bit too
quickly
and sacrificing a piece easy ER for us
as competitions we can always take it
back if it doesn't work out the engine
supports that sacrifice as the white
king would have been the one out in the
open but here it seems very obvious what
White's plan is H4 let's take on G5 open
HR you say no with G4 I play H5 I'm
gonna play H6 your knight is loose on F6
and black wants to play A5 but I guess
the point is he's not quite in time
White's attack is stronger
yeah A5 I guess as a move it all feels a
little bit slow I guess we're just going
to take here and after Knight takes I
mean queen H4 is coming there's always
tactics with Knight D5 as well let's say
Knight gh7 to this launch the Knight and
F6 so it feels like white attack is
coming a lot a lot faster so and now
Gianna is thinking he should have
thought on the last move with Knight xc5
but Robert this really seems to be the
storyline of the match like Jan is in
control he wins the game but he's
letting origin back into the match too
easily
and this is both his Blessing and his
curse that Jan is such a fast thinker
that he will be able to Blitz out all
these moves but sometimes he plays a
little bit too quickly and here the
Knight goes out to G4 and he sacks the
piece but it might be too late I still
like what he's going for you have to
cause problems for arjun's King
yeah for sure so let's see what the
origin's gonna do is he gonna take the
Knight is he gonna leave it leave it
there you can think on G5 but I guess
black is now pretty fast with most like
Knight A4 or queen 63 would lead a
Checkmate so I don't think he can
completely ignore what yon is doing on a
queen side and he does take
and he goes Knight C4 but the engine
says black is right back in this thing
the Knight on C4 is loose this looks
much more difficult to play at the
moment for white whose King is about to
be exposed
yeah Bishop B6 nice move by yawn but I
can take here but I guess you take on C4
and a good thing for yon is that after
Queen H4 you always still have a move
like F6 to create some blue for your
king
wait it's saying made in 10.
over yeah Queen B2 there Nate oh
wow do you think Arjun just missed the
move Queen takes a three wait this this
is over Robert yeah I think he did and
you see Arjun he's holding his head and
now here's a big question for you if
Arjun wants he can wait out the rest of
his clock and this will be the final
game do you think he wants one more
good question I mean it will be a game
with the black pieces in the three plus
one portion
I I don't know I mean generally you
would think the more games the better
for him okay Queen E3 Jan still has to
finish it off but I think it's pretty
straightforward now I mean King C2
there's 19 C3 and after King B1 you go
Bishop Bishop two check okay Bishop B3
that is fine and science John does win
the game all right so there is still
time for another game in the Sleep three
percent portion
and if Arjun comes back to win this game
of the match we would have to ask him
about this point because he could have
let his time elapse we could have headed
straight into the bullet but perhaps
when you have a deficit you feel I need
to get these victories right now I can't
wait until those final 30 minutes at
least this gives you another game in the
mix
right and so here we see another French
John switches it up and he goes for the
Taurus variation with 92 move 3 Bishop
G5 white also wants to go Bishop H4 to
G3 to trade up this bishop on D6 which
is Black's best minor piece now young
goes for A3 trying to expand on the
queen side and what does Arjun do here
he goes Bishop B8 and he wants to go
Bishop H5 to bring his Bishop into the
game that way yeah this is a vintage
french position where instead of having
a bad light Square Bishop you bring it
out into the open go after White's
Knights and you see Arjun he's happy
he's moved quickly and Jan stops Bishop
H5 before it becomes a thing that's
definitely a good move
yeah 93 stop English stage five I like
it now he can also go rookie one putting
a lot of pressure on that pawn and E6
which is no longer defended so I like I
like yellen's position you're here I
guess he's gonna pick the H pawn bishop
H5 is there
but is black really threatening to take
I think for the moment not as white
always has to move Bish takes H7 at the
end and Knight takes D4 first is
definitely an option but Bishop takes H7
still going to be White's reply but
these are tactics that need time before
you can just make your move you need to
calculate these things and here he does
play rookie one I do not think Arjun
will be playing Knight 64 but he might
play H6 because then Knight takes D4 is
a threat
a nice point there so maybe Yana has to
go Bishop to E3 as otherwise he would go
down upon and there we have it but this
gives arguing the opportunity to go
Knight to E4 it's now the E4 squares
only controlled once by wide end so you
cannot take so he goes Knight G4 instead
putting pressure on the bishop but I
think white would not mind the trade you
can just recapture with the Rook you
keep your pressure here goes Bishop 4
instead I like to position you for net
for for young I think strategically he's
got a lot of charms with the bishop pair
the weak pawn and E6 and this potential
Outpost for his Knight and E5
this is strategically terrible for black
and that's why he strikes with G5 he
agrees with you Benjamin he says I'm
going to be in trouble if I let white
Goku moves like Queen D2 rookie two
rookie one so I need to act right here
and now and this bishop 8 on H5 it does
pin this Knight on F3 so there might be
some tactics available some Knight takes
D4 or Knight takes F2 first followed by
Knight takes D4 things of that nature is
Knight F2 and G4 these are all ideas but
you have to make them work
yeah so let's see if he's gonna go for
it I think Knight exf2 certainly is
tempting like he said strategically it
all looks very dangerous for black if
white can go like Queen E2 Bishop C3
because Queen E2 but the evil bar hates
that move Robert is there maybe someone
like E5 takes Knight takes and how do
you solve the problem with the nine and
the three I don't see it and again Jan
moved very quickly it's almost two
minutes remaining there's no reason to
play Queen E2 in one second E5 looks
great you blast open the center E5 to E4
is a threat of course and look at this
position if you take Knight ge5 their
pins Galore suddenly originates the
Opera yeah I missed it you saw his face
he kind of squint and he's like wait
what oh no
I I don't see it I don't see what you're
doing here I mean if you think of the
Knight I guess there might be Knight
takes D4 which also looks extremely
problematic it's or I mean there's got
to be something for black so let's see
E4 for the moment is a threat forking
the bishop and the Knight I mean the
pawn looks bad because the Knight looks
bad maybe you move the bishop but then
again there is the movie four
this looks very difficult for whoa what
night
he's got a number of wins 1964 attacking
the queen young sex is Queen but he's
only getting one minus Robert no he he
completely missed it I saw his face
there he did not see Knight takes E2
with check he just played a very bad
game he was missing everything I think
John would be the first person to admit
that but Benjamin not a single tactic in
that game went his way that was not the
way to end the three minute if you're
young but arches on the other hand it
justifies his decision to resign in the
penultimate game
yeah I know a crucial win for origin he
keeps it within one point that gives him
a lot of chances to still come back in
the bullet portion Robert it's quite
shocking I mean over here
over here Jan will still do well but in
the next three moves he lost the game
just play Move Like Bishop C3 defend the
pawn and white still has an edge but now
it's uh it's anyone's match here as we
go into the bullet only a one point lead
for Jana Palms Arjun aragaisy he decides
to end it not with a loss but he gets
that last game he wins and that means
that it's just a point separating the
two the players they're gonna take a
break and before we do the same we want
to shout out a very special event that
is happening in February of next year so
introducing the first ever chess kid
national festival join us in Charlotte
North Carolina for four days of Chess
facilities including over the board
tournaments and opportunities to meet
special guests like Gotham chess fun
Master Mike and chief chess officer why
that's his title nobody will ever really
know Danny wrench that's right Gotham
fun Master Mike and Danny wrench will be
at the festival which takes place
February 6 16th and 19th and we cannot
wait to see you there use the command
Festival in chat to learn more and
register today subscribers stay tuned
for a special message from fun Master
Mike during the break so Benjamin I we
might be at the chesskit festival next
year but that's your way after the break
it's the finale the bullet portion of
this features Championship presented by
coinbase the match has gone to Palm
Street versus argentinaire geissi do not
go anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
four years chess kit has had lots of fun
online events but it's finally time for
us to go IRL in real life puzzle
competitions a main event and all sorts
of other fun things to do announcing the
chess kid National Festival
come along you'll need fun Master Mike
there
I'm going to the Chaska Festival I'm
going to the chest Good Festival
[Music]
smearch is coming to chess.com
enchant your pieces with one of two
spells jump or freeze players start with
two jump spells and five free spells
which we charge after five moves you may
catch your spare whenever you wish
before making a regular chest move jump
is a spare cast to one square wherein if
there is a piece on that square other
pieces can jump over the Charmed piece
the freeze spell is cashed over a three
by three square area and the pieces in
this area are temporarily Frozen in
place
combine your powers of Chess and sorcery
to defeat your opponent
see what supercell and chess.com have
cooked up in our new variant spell chess
dropping on September 1st
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase the
year is 2023 young the Palm she leads
Arjun eragisi by one point but bad June
if we could go back in time I'm sure
young would want a few games to go in a
different direction he still has a lead
and he has a shot to win and face Magnus
Carls in the next round
still has a one point lead however it
feels like it could have perhaps been a
bigger leap and like you said Robert the
winner of this match has a pretty easy
match in the quarterfinals they only
have to play this guy Manus Carlson
and Jana panchi he knows that foe very
well they've played a world championship
match and of course Magnus won that
quite handily but that pivotal game
where Magnus got that first win things
could have gone a different way in that
world championship Clash of course Jan
had a nice position but Magnus outlasted
him so for yada policy Benjamin it's
sometimes a tale of what if things had
gone just a little bit differently
exactly and same thing in this match
like what would have happened had he not
disconnected right like what would have
happened had he just won this game or
with a white piece he would have had a
three-point lead but right now it's down
at one point the games are going to get
started very soon and actually as we
speak Robert we are off
and Arjun goes back to his trusty
English opening and we see it's a
quieter start to this game but it's
bullet chess we know that the action
will blow the board open in any moment
what you can go for here is plans of The
Rook G1 followed by G4 but Arjun keeps
it very quiet he just goes kingside
castle and go Rook 81. I feel like here
Jan should be doing fine Robert who do
you think is overall the favorite in the
bullet like who do you think is more
comfortable I think Arjun is he just
plays much more regularly as played in
the bullet Chess Championship uh he's
younger so he's more likely to have
grown up playing bullet chess uh but
right now in this particular position I
also like it for Arjun look at his
Bishop on B2 look at his growing attack
I think Jana's done a great job of
Defending but it feels easier for white
to play because he's the initiative
for sure you had to move Bishop 3
perhaps is a little bit maybe there were
even options to go like H4 H5 to kick
the Knight away A6 the Knight jumps back
to C3 and B5 nice move by Young to try
to create some counter play on The Queen
side
do not take that pawn on B5 that opens
up the flank for The Rook I think that
would be a huge mistake and Knight E4
that's a nice move look at the bishop on
B2 look at that H7 ng7 pawn it looks
dangerous for black you need to be very
careful
yeah yellow decides to trade on G5 but
it doesn't quite solve all of his
problems Bishop C3 the pawn on C4 is
weak but not opponent G5 is hanging so
maybe white has to go H4 first now John
has the time to go Queen E5 or queen E3
but I guess origen will keep the queen
size queen G4 here Queen G4 looks
excellent the Black Knight can go to E5
and then to D3 there's no way white
wants to take that Knight the biggest
Advantage the biggest Plus in the
position is the bishop on C3 it's better
than the Knight but after 95 Queen G3
Knight D3 where's the follow-up for
white
yeah I I think White's plan is just to
go H5 H6 carva D darshwares and it looks
super dangerous for black like if the
screen ever lands here it's just going
to be Checkmate I don't know maybe you
have I mean queen of five Queen
somewhere maybe you have to go like F5
to keep it closed F5 is played by Jana
pumps he loves on person but that's an
umbrella pawn it Shields the black king
with Rook F7 ideas to follow so look at
that oh Rook have said apparently a
mistake but that is the natural
follow-up
I like Ruby one by origin this working
F7 is completely tied up now he's
switching his attention to the queen
side with like Rook B6 going after this
one over here this looks terrible for
black rugby six such a good idea but he
allowed the Knight to go into D4 which I
think has to have been a mistake but
whoa he allows the trade I guess he says
the F6 Pawn is not a weakness to
strengthen both players they're making
inaccuracies
by Young he perhaps wants to go Rook to
D5 get Rook F3 played Queen E2 it feels
like Arjun has to be better here but I
don't quite see okay now he can trade I
think that's a big early for Yan whose
Queen side pawns cannot be set in motion
or Rook D5 goes 35 pawn and if E5 Falls
next goes F6 then H6 blacks passers they
look very dangerous here and arjun's
under now six seconds he has to move
yeah rookie five okay so maybe just Rook
to C5 defend upon King F7 Black's moves
are very natural here and it feels like
perhaps Jan can score the first win of
the Buller portion this would be huge
for Yan because his position looked very
tough it's still an end game that is
tricky but the H6 Pawn will drop at a
critical moment and black should have an
extra Pawn
way but I mean you take this spot over
here but white can go after the C pawn
and he still says that passed April Rook
C2 but I think White's fine here takes
on C3 I think it might just be headed
for a draw H5 yes the a pawn will push
the G and H pawns will push I think
we'll see Mass liquidation but for yawn
it will take a while and that's good
news what do you think about this King
on A6 in front of the pawn
I think it's just gonna be a draw like
why it's going to push over here Black's
gonna push on the king side and
eventually both sides will end up giving
up uh their their Rooks okay arjun's
just gonna sit here and there's nothing
black can do to improve the position
to draw
okay yeah I guess the thing is as soon
as Black's pawns are off the board it's
immediately a draw so black needs to
keep both of them
all right okay yeah it's it's still just
the draw takes an aid
and that guy what a game Robert it
starts pretty well for origin but at
some point Nepal was definitely in the
driver's seat
it took nearly five minutes off the
clock so Arjun did have a winning
position at some point but uh nepo
defended well and had the edge even into
the end game so what I'm asking you
Benjamin after that start it may have
been spoiled chances for both who do you
think is feeling better with the rest of
the bullet
I think I think Jan he hang on in the
time scramble we were saying earlier
that we feel like origin is a better
player but I often actually say you're
not playing him in uh in the in the time
scramble so this one can really go
either way and Robert we have an
interesting change of pace we see John
opening up with uh with G with like a
reverse modern but actually opening
Arjun hung that pawn on D5
look at this H Pawn up the board origin
shows no fear he's playing like Alpha
zero maybe we should call it origin zero
but this is zeroing in a Checkmate
attack how do you stop this
I guess well there's no way to stop
Queen H3 but it doesn't hurt us that
much we go like King G1 or King F2 and
then later kick the queen away with like
Knight G1 but black has a long lasting
initiative you go like Knight F7 maybe
Queen side castles F5 at the right
moment and white king is always going to
be weak so it's it's unpleasant to play
this for young especially given the fact
that this is a bullet game and Arjun
he's up on the clock his position is far
easier to play uh Castle Queen side F5
as you mentioned I don't see how white
survives this with no time on the clock
yeah and I'm really surprised by Jan
yeah I don't like this book at all I
thought he should have just gone
queenside Castle but I just wanted to
point out I think Jan should have just
stuck with E4 seemed to be working out
pretty well for him he was getting
advantages he was getting some
initiative if you played a reverse
modern I guess the nice thing is that as
a cheater you can pre-move Bishop G2 but
other than that you can easily end up in
a worse position
how did he get out of this I think I
know the answer at black Castle kingside
instead of Queen side and now there's no
more attack white is completely
stabilized Benjamin Argent needs to make
the most of chances like that he can't
be castling kingside in that position
now it definitely felt like a missed
opportunity queenside castles would have
given him a nice attacking chance he
goes Knight G5 but I guess we just take
and does he just want to take with the F
Pawn it would throw the Rook takes F2
and would also allow him to put the
Knight on D4 so maybe you just ignore
what black is doing if you take you
recapture and white is doing completely
fine so that's a really good move of
Rook D7 I thought there'd be Queen H3
but of course the Knight on F2 covered
that square so we're seeing trades and
at this point without an outside pass
Pawn the game should be level but
mistakes happen without time
yeah 94 nice movie originally King Kong
now move to E3 due to Knight C2 with a
fork so maybe now you go A4 followed by
King here okay goes H4 maybe there's
Knight B5 by origin followed by and here
again Knight B5 how about Knight C3 and
that's why he went A4 to stop the knife
from getting there and Knight C2 doesn't
threaten anything the 93 is in a perfect
situation
the black king is very close like Knight
E6 to C5 you have to look out for that
I think Jonas thinking way too many
liberties with all of these Pawn pushes
Knight C5 here there still might be two
the Knight C4 to follow I this feels
like it should be a troll but how we can
give a check and like G5 it's G5 and
move while he goes for it
an amazing find that is so nice you put
H6 there and then G6 you don't take back
on H6 the Black Knight would go to D6
and F7 and here we see it's going to be
a pod race the black can go after the a
pawn what is white going to do here I
feel like both sides can lose this
yeah young going all out on the king
side but it feels like black spawn is
running way faster down on board A4 A3
how do you stop the pawn 93 but you
should be able to shoulder the Knight
away
yes King C3 and then after Knight moves
Knight C5 take away all the squares from
that night
okay now two one how do you do those got
three seconds Knight eight two wait now
okay can you take no there was another
move 93
okay it's gonna be a three-time
repetition if he goes by C3
83 I think that's a three-fold what a
what an escape by yawn wow
yawn The Palms he survives it keeps the
one point lead that took a lot of time
off the match clock but Benjamin what
we're seeing is Arjun coming oh so close
to tying up the scoreboard but Jan he
refuses to lose
exactly yeah very very close match I
think this one should have just been a
draw but John was thinking way too many
liberties with all those bomb pushes and
all of a sudden origin went for it on
the queen side and he should have won
the one but uh yeah Jana keeps his lead
and as we see already almost 10 minutes
off the clock so with every draw John is
getting closer and closer and Roberts
what does this move Rook to G1
he was just avoiding the Queen's eyes
and look at this queen trade being
offered Beyond the Palm she playing some
high level opening stuff here and I like
Black's position it looks like you're
much better coordinated but white hasn't
sacrificed anything
yeah it feels like you got an initiative
here pretty much for free I guess you
just go like Bishop to A5 keeping the
pin on the Knight and there we have it
and it's difficult for white to develop
you you can no longer go kingside Castle
I therefore assume you're gonna have to
go for Queen side castles but it's not
going to be that easy to achieve so I
guess Bishop B6 here keeping you some
pressure on the pawn and Jana's a very
comfortable position I think white will
play Knight A4 after Bishop B6 is go
after the bishop pair and if that was
gonna be the case why not hurt White's
Pawn structure but look at this there's
open space for the Bishops this is
either side's chance in this game
rookie six a crafty Moon by Young he
wants to recapture with Rook or maybe go
Rook B6 Rook B2 start attacking white
again this King over here stuck you
cannot Castle here you cannot I mean you
can but that doesn't look very
comfortable maybe just Rook E8 and there
we have it this looks like it's all
young if white kid Castle White's
probably better but the fat oh no don't
go that direction Bishop F5 with Rook B1
is gonna be a checkmate at some point
right so H takes a little bit slow okay
but now I mean there's almost like 93
Bishop five Bishop 5 looks like a nice
way you might have to go E4 and give the
problem yon just takes though
but he thinks he's gonna make the king
with Knight A3 and Rook B1
but is it actually made like there must
be a defense right
or these are not like candy wanted yeah
King D1 after 93 because rugby 293 wow
origin hanging on
wait what do you do here yeah this is
actually very tricky the bishop on F4 is
protecting the D2 Square the Knight on
D3 is saving the check on the B2 square
but something Rook B to C2 you have to
go King D1 and oh it looks like it's
there
oh wait all of a sudden he's lost Knight
G4 okay but Rook takes F2 or maybe
Knight takes distills anyone's game it
goes F5
tonight
now it's completely the origin should
win this game
now it's a free piece right it's a full
extra piece and you're just gonna mop up
the pawns now it's easy so Jan to pomsi
he missed a chance to survive but it was
very tricky and Arjun who didn't have an
impressive opening he's suddenly going
to even this match up
yeah very tough loss here for young he
it felt like he was going to open up a
two-point lead but right now it's it's
all even all right so yawn again opening
up with the reverse modern and it turns
back into a king's Indian with uh with
the fiancado
and it's a slower system it's not in the
attacking King's Indian this is going to
be more of a positional Affair and
yesterday while content with Donna he
said he likes the C6 and D6 Pawn
structures for black he finds them very
flexible in bullet chess and white E4
pawn and C4 Pawn those can be attacked
by the Black Knights
yeah I like to move A4 by origin he's
grabbing a little bit more space on a
queen signal he goes Queen A5 there's
Queen B4 that's annoying and to be fair
these spawns on C4 and E4 are always
targets that being said though white
does have more space and the D6 Pawn can
be targeted as well now you can take on
C4 as Bishop of one traps your queen but
you just move the queen back and you
want to go Knight B6 on the next move to
Target this pawn and some people may ask
why would you buy Queen before just to
move it back look at what happened is
White's Pawn structure is shattered
black has firm control over the queen
side stole a pawn in the center this
looks very risky look at the King on
Jean it's wide open
yeah I don't think this was a clever
Punker but origin looks extremely risky
like I said with all the weak dark
swears Knight G5 nice move by yon in
case you take I mean maybe you take it I
don't know I don't feel like this should
be possible but hey maybe it is yeah
Bishop takes F6 Knight back to E6 just
blocking the Rooks from staring at each
other and eventually maybe you play
Queen F5 is black try to trade those
Queens off the board so this is hanging
on by a thread maybe bishop six is
Bishop F5 actually I'm thinking about
that Intermezzo hitting that Queen on C2
and then playing Knight to E4 E6 but
this looks very risky
yo what up with this Robert Bishop F5
there's Queen F2 and after 96 then you
go G4 and the bishop all of a sudden
this trap so maybe you have to go to E4
but maybe then you take and you take
here a goose Queen B2 okay he's going
after the problem B7 but now 94 feels
like it holds it together for black
we see the Bishops of opposite color oh
not only is it holding her black is
there some kind of Checkmate attack with
Rook B8 Rook B2 coming you don't have
Bishop D4 because of this so he goes
Rook takes but now there's gotta be a
knockout punch for black where is it
Queen D7 I guess offer the trade of
Queens
and Defenders after check you can go
here that's so important that H3 is
Defender I completely missed that Queen
D7 is the only move to survive but nepo
hasn't played yet and he finally five
rugby two you go King G1 and after check
and here
also the Rooks but the point is that
after takes takes there's always vertex
C4 Rook d8
so white could turn this around I mean
Arjun has plenty of time 20 seconds on
the clock but he's worse now once the
Queens come off the board
right so let's see what he's gonna do I
mean I guess he's gonna give a check but
King back I don't see it this one like I
said could easily turn around 12 seconds
arjun's clock is sticking as well
he's gonna have to trade Queens I think
he is forced at this point five
threading Checkmate over here tricky
move takes up Pawn okay maybe now Jan
can move okay goes Queen C7
C5 yeah he's Gotta Move rope okay
they're just making random moves in
between five
oh and Arjun wins on time and takes the
lead what a game and you see yawn he is
distraught that game was one where at
first a young looked like he was in
charge then tactics went in arjun's
favor but when it came down to the final
seconds it was Arjun who would handle
this clock better we see a tied match
once again so Benjamin back to Catalan
here whose chances do you like in chat
you can answer the question yourselves
a 2C trade on these seven and then now
okay wait so for the moment you want to
stop a pawn but there he goes Queen
Dixie four it feels like here origin
should have the advantage with the
bishop error so I think perhaps young
should have tried to hang on to the
spawn a little more firmly origin gives
up his Bishop pair for the better Pawn
structure and he should just be
comfortable better here I mean look at
these weaknesses on C6 and C7
the season weaknesses are real the B2
Pawn is going to be targeted by the
black Rooks Rook F to B8 That's The Rook
you bring over to keep A5 safe and sound
so it looks bad for black but white does
not have an easy time getting that
Bishop out of C1
exactly a bishop F6 putting more
pressure on B2 you can also go for like
H5 here and H4 which is annoying playing
The Rook can be three followed by Rook
B8 it feels like Jana's doing very fine
here even though he's got this slightly
response structure
and this queen C8 Rook A6 configuration
defending the A4 pawn and C6 pawn it
looks odd I have to admit and now it
looks very bad for black because if the
Bishops are off the board these Rook end
games are gonna be favorable for white
yeah this looks very nice for origin not
opponent C6 is weak and it's very
difficult for black to ever increase the
pressure D4 though I don't know we see
yon trying to go H5 the position now
becomes a little bit locked it feels
like if anything white should have these
slide Edge but you know black isn't
doing too bad he can double up Direction
the b-file and uh he he should be able
to hold here I would think oh he's
tripling on the B file we're gonna have
a Lincoln's gun down to the B2 as pawn
and that would be Mass liquidation so
Rook takes B2 is possible instead maybe
yawn's playing for a win here doesn't
want to trade all the pieces
whatever this Robert fix V2 Rook takes
C6 and Rook at five it goes Rook D6
which is a little bit passive now Queen
into an origin keeps it all together
and look at the clock though Yawn is
well ahead on time 10 seconds Plus for
him so he's just trying to keep the
action he doesn't want to allow easy
choices from White
okay so Rook B5 he's giving up the April
and going after the beep on maybe Rook
C2 by origin if you want to keep it
together no he goes for the trade okay
so queen of three nice move not allowing
black to activate their own Queen with
upon a C5
King G7 and the queen D5 Rook B1 things
like that it looks scary for the YK
exactly especially in bullet so if Arjun
wants he could just liquidate the here
he goes Rook C4 okay maybe now I check
and like Queen here or Rook a one
followed by Queen B1 Auto there's always
Queen there's no threat like oh Queen B3
there's no threat especially because the
queen can't even get to D1 and that was
eight white has all the threats so queen
of eight is fourth but it's very passive
this looks horrible for black and there
goes the Rook Rock
oh my gosh the rook and Arjun takes it
and takes a two-point lead in this match
what a shocking game all of a sudden
Giannis completely lost control over
this match he's down two points and
we're back in the French so let's see
what he will do here he takes on F6 but
this looks very comfortable for for
black
yeah these positions have been looking
pretty good for ours you remember his
Bishop went to E8 and out to H5 in a
previous game and so Jan he continues to
go into this variation thinking of the
control of the e-file and that backwards
Pawn E6 but backwards Pawn no more
exactly origin breaks in the center with
E5 okay so I suppose John has to take
take again and go Knight D2 and he still
should be doing fine but Robert he
really needs to win here he really needs
to come back into the match there's 11
minutes on the clock there's still time
but this one has to turn around
completely I mean before he was up like
two points but now he's behind
and it doesn't look good in this
position I would take the black side of
this it looks like look at this the
Knight coming to F4 uh there's going to
be an initiative against the white king
I don't see white getting an attack
against black
yeah let's see what he's going to do I
mean maybe a move like C4 he goes Jesus
this G3 Now The Bishop's trap what
does he want G5 because at least it
looks complicated with the G6 Square
potentially vulnerable but G5 it should
objectively be very good for white and
for black excuse me
Bishop H3 instead okay now you can take
an F1 I guess you have to recapture with
an i but Knight F6 it goes neither six
right away all right so let's see what
he is going to do I mean
it looks if if John loses this game it
might almost be mathematically over he
he needs to come back as quickly as
possible so we should remind everybody
that as long as there's one second on
the match clock that game will start and
yours point of rookie six that black
queen it's almost threatened Bishop
takes F6 is a pretty nasty threat he's
trying to open up the black king
British takes F6 and there we have
politics I mean even Knight takes a form
and look at the lights crash around
black skin I mean maybe just a check
Netflix one and you just play for a
conversation this king is so weak but
now origin has the time to go rookie
eight in a bullet game you have to feel
like white wins this type of position
the majority of the time he goes Rook E5
I guess he's doing a great job of
Defending with activity
Queenie okay takes on B2 variable now
Queen G4 comes in and like Queen g6s
looks extremely scary for black this has
to be winning for white F6 is hanging
you can't easily protect him Bishop d8
allows critics H6 check and the attack
continues no no no this looks like a bad
game for origin
it takes an E3 okay white can take over
here and take an E3 but now white skin
also is going to be a little bit exposed
King E8 okay like it's running
but running to where is the big question
Queen H7 check and a queen H6 check no
you can take and take here
can you okay checks there first I like
the queen of the H6 so you can take your
take and the king size is pretty safe on
H3
we check and pick up the bishop pick up
the bishop and you can pick up any
service Checkmate
no it doesn't go for a mate continue
Benjamin I like to say when you see mate
look for better he says an extra piece
will do
okay he's just gonna trade here and it's
gonna be a win for young but I was just
about to say origin is gonna play it out
as he has the lead in the match and he
wants to move the clock as much as
possible
it's something he might have done if he
considered it because it's smart to
waste time when you have a leap but I
think Arjun trusts his bullet skills and
we see this position it's like a
Blumenfeld reverse where white has given
up a pawn but has huge attacking
potential in the king side
breaking back in the center okay so
origin just goes Knight bd2 stopping the
fork with E4 yawn trades but I like
white center here I like white center
there's always the D5 push you have to
open file you've got this diagonal for
your Bishop also the other one this one
looks great for white sticks F6 oh
this looks terrible for black but at
least you have a double-edged position
so you might get checkmated that's the
bad news the good news is you might also
get some kind of uh plan around the
white king because look at this dark
Square Bishop the E3 Square things like
that
yeah he's Level Playing Bishop E3 how do
you defend the pawn if you take opponent
C5 the opponent D6 is also with Queen A5
Jan is making a comeback here if he wins
this game he would tie it up again and
Robert I don't yeah there goes the C
pawn and he should be doing great here
this looks amazing for blood F and clear
extra Pawn but it's really two extra
pawns on the queen side to that one pass
Pawn on D6 so if you can make use of the
Pongo to D7 things like that that could
be trouble and he goes Rook E8 allowing
D7 with Tempo does he think it's easier
to win that pawn when it's pushed all
the way up there
I guess so I mean I don't see how you
defend a rook d8 and there it goes and
the problem for Robert is that why this
pinned you kind of go King and join you
hang the Knight and so that is going to
be a big problem those 94 okay but now
do you just take or something five jump
yeah that's a good idea uh from origin
here what does black queen C3 pin the
Knight no yeah you can get away with it
that's a nice move that's a nice move
because Queen E5 also very nice keeping
full control but maybe now it actually
takes a knight of five although you can
always flick in Bishop too
uh it takes the Rook to avoid that exact
fork and it's an extra Pawn for black
and d7's falling The Rook can go back to
E7 or Knight to f8 this should be very
clean for nepo
yes we see rookie one all right so let's
see how he will finish this one off okay
he actually if he takes our thing he's
up two pawns I thought he was a one but
he's up two Pawn so he has to win this
game repeat oh you have to take that's a
great try though at least you know you
can catch your opponent off guard and
now he gets to chase those black Pawns
yeah but nepo just hangs on to his extra
pawns he's still up too but you know the
king is still active maybe if you can
move him to B5 but it feels like black
is just in time I guess with the King to
C7 or yes I like this one even better
with the Knight of D5 right because
white can never trade Knights that would
be an easy winning end game for black
and with the Knight on D5 the king is
free to run around
and Knight C3 great move by Young if he
trades off the knights he moves into a
winning Kingdom pawn and game B5 this
one is over
easily winning at this stage for Young
by the way young with 30 seconds on his
clock look at how fast he is in these
type patrols and the point now is that
white gets a pass Pawn but the black
king chases it down and then the white
king cannot stop the black passer both
in the center and on the queen side
king of six here is a pretty routine win
that's what I would go for here and
after King C4 you just go B3 trade
everything off and winning the king side
Giannis thinking though goes E4 which is
winning because if okay B3
A3 and he he wins with the two Passover
all right so we are all even Robert with
five minutes on the clock we are indeed
and now Jana palmchi on a winning streak
the match is tied a lot of people
thought that Arjun would be the favorite
in bullet he actually leads the bullet
4-3 but it was four to one so now we
have this position here where black is
competing for the center white goes
Knight B5 Benjamin I like these
positions for white I love myself a good
Bishop pair
Center here and good development so the
force the move here or Bishop G4 E4 is
definitely an idea here so I don't know
I like this position for for black H3
maybe you go between 5 or trade over
here but Robert this game is super
important whoever wins this one we'll
we'll take a lead going into the
probably what's going to be the final
game
yes and we see that this position looks
very passive for white so that's what
you were saying you're right Benjamin
that white has a pair of Bishops but not
open diagonals thanks as D5 and E5 Pawns
in the center and some moves need to be
easily played Black put the Rook to d8
White doesn't have such easy moves the
position's cramped
right but for the moment like you said
he does have the bishop pair D4 I think
a nice one by origin to create some
tension in the center now he gets the
open evil for his Rook so the bishop 22
will feel a little bit uncomfortable so
let's see what he's gonna do I mean wait
does nepo have this move number now 95
to F4 or Knight C3 this looks this looks
scary
this looks terrible that Knight goes
into F4 that's really bad news for white
and he can still go Knight D5 at any
moment but the D4 Pawn is what nepa's
going after
or it's H3 you go Bishop H5 keep all the
tension and it goes Bishop H Bishop 5
possible but now the visual can just
move back to F1 and I think Jan has got
the worst behind him here and maybe down
the line the spot on D4 can become
somewhat weak it's overextended so why
not go after it's hard for black to
bring more reinforcements that Pawnee
says no Rook trade for you black people
A5 A4 at the right moment try to go
after White's Queen side I think that
Queen C1 is an indication that he would
like to fight on that side of the board
but you hit a one move threat it was
avoided
especially three Queen back to the eight
Queen C5 okay he's still in this line
but there's no good Discovery from like
95 but wait now he can take the pawn
that's a pretty big Pawn and he takes it
uh oh that opens up the long dangle
against the black king if you chop on oh
it makes a blunder afterwards there goes
another Pawn but wait but if you take
there might be B5 don't there's B5 oh
right this is very tricky the queen he's
got 17 seconds where is he gonna go
Queenie fights again nice move by Young
because B6 he can still save his Queen
back to uh oh sorry A4 and he Retreats
his Queen but black has an initiative
here uh Rook C2 was an idea through the
fork oh he works into the wrong piece oh
Queen F6 and you hit F2 take an A2 good
fine Rook a two rookie wants a threat
H2
this is a nerve-wracking game this won't
be the final game so even if someone is
sex and never pre-moved three
or vertex F1 wait Arjun is crushing can
you shoot but Knight F3 you pick up the
queen it doesn't Queen G3 and it's scary
Bishop
oh it's Queen D1 training hurry the fan
okay
three
okay anyone's game but I feel like black
skin is safer okay he offers the queen
trade
a young keeping the Queens on the board
this is smart play uh from Young
centralizing his Queen and Arjun he
might go for the repetition
no he doesn't
oh he does there we have it Robert it's
all of a sudden a sudden death game
whoever wins this game will win the
match and if they draw we will get four
games of one plus one so we will have a
four game mini match but this will be
the final game if we have a winner the
match is over Magnus Carlson will know
his opponent but right now Arjun goes
back to his trusty opening he likes to
go with these D4 setups Benjamin they
have to keep their nerves
yeah it is all about Nurse here Robert
whoever wins this game wins the match
Rook seat John is setting up C5 so Arjun
takes on D5 you can recapture with the
bishop here but then Bishop B6 is going
to be a little bit annoying but yeah
what a match what do you match Robert
should be seven here
oh black and strength with C5 the E4
Pawn is also a bit looser he goes D5 now
even iqp but that's a passer it's an
unopposed pawn and I can go up to D6 at
any moment
yeah but I like how Jana's doing this he
goes quickness trying to trade off the
queens and I feel like the spawn is
often going to turn into a weakness but
now the A7 Pawn is hanging not easy to
deal without if you go A5 there's Bishop
B5 so A6 nice move if you cannot take
because of rookie eight that's right and
I don't like where the queen is if he
goes Queen A4 he wants to redirect over
to the king side Queen G4 now and he's
attacking the Knight but that D5 pawn it
might fall in the next few moves
yeah great game so far by Young A4
trying to attack the pawn on B5 and
maybe just Queen B6 defend and Knight F6
is coming goes Knight B6 but Robert this
one might just be headed for a try it's
looking pretty even so far that being
said I slightly prefer yawn's position
this guy can hop to like F4 or C3 and he
still has some tactics
they're definitely attacked his watch
out and moving H5 with Knight H3 check
with Queen takes F3 if actually if white
goes Queen G5 right now Knight H3 check
might win the game
it was Knight G5 wait he's hanging The
Prodigy too he goes H5 Inside by young
but thinks F7 and The Rook is
hanging at the end so Bishops
three is not the move Bishop D5 he
cannot take us over 92. what do you do
what do you do you have nothing because
rookie won you still take 92 Rook D1
mate it's a back ranked checkmate
I I don't see the move for I don't see
the move for argue you can't move your
queen you hang the Knight what what do
you even play here if the bishop can't
go anywhere
there are no moves clock is ticking that
is cheaper just take it straight forward
take a seat and take an F1 that's the
match that is the match yeah
he takes he's threatening the queen move
your queen to G6 go Queen G6
it should be two checks it should be two
and there goes the Knight and that's it
Robert that's it Queen G5 don't hang the
record queen of six
just take the pawns you are up a full
Rook Queen F6 back Rook to D4 that
should be that
Queen D6 straight of the queens and that
is it what what a match Robert
oh my goodness she wins at the last game
he can't even believe in himself and he
shakes his head but he is the one who
will be moving on to face Magnus Carlson
Arjun irrigation gave him everything
that he could handle but when all is
said and done Janda pumps she advances
the quarterfinals to 15 and a half 14 F
win Benjamin that was exhilarating
what a match Robert we saw everything we
saw yon taking the lead that Arjun came
back but at the end Jan had a stronger
nurse and moves on to the quarter finals
against Magnus
wow wow wow there really are no words
for the matchups that we've seen
recently and young Palm she takes this
one against Arjun Eric icy what a nail
biter what a close finish and you have
to feel for Arjun for the second year in
a row he can't get out of the first
round because he loses a close one
yeah what an absolutely
very deserveably moves on he was leading
for most of the match he had some bad
luck with the disconnect but how he
pulled his nerve together in the final
two or three games was extremely
impressive Robert
really was I can't get over what we just
saw but we should go to our Savvy moves
presented by coinbase where we'll be
reviewing Eric a key moment from a game
with yonda palmchi winning the match and
I think we should just go in that last
game there Benjamin because the move
that won him the event was a pretty
sweet move and that was our Savvy move
of the day presented by coinbase
right so it was this move here Bishop to
D5 he not only defends the opponent F7
but now he also threatens to take this
bishop on C4 followed by 92 and there's
nothing you can do with white if you
take the bishop again 92 you pick up the
queen with check actually also so so
what do you do if you go let's say
rookie one you still take on C4 Eco 92
anyway because in case you take the Rook
D1 and it's Checkmate so after a long
long think Arjun finally settled on the
Move Knight H3 but this does not help
now you take the bishop and ethernetics
afford the Rook is hanging and if you
take you even get a check made it over
here so Arjun he took an H5 but after a
queen A1 it was just all over yanos
upper rook and after Bishop B2 he also
won the Knight and he won the match and
that was your Savvy move of the day
presented by coinbase what a sick move
Bishop D5 everyone was staring at the
king side but no he says that Bishop is
overloaded it won him the game and the
match and as we see in the bracket
Yonder Palms his name is the one across
from Magnus Carlson in the lower half of
the bracket we have our quarterfinal
match set there Jan against Magnus I
think some people will be very happy to
see that rematch
yeah and this one this is going to be an
exciting one Jan however will have to
play better to get chance against Magnus
he uh you're not gonna get that many
that many opportunities so he really has
to make most of it
so janapamshi he gets to play Magnus
Carlson next the winner will face Wesley
so but we are going to see another
matchup take place right after this one
so Yanda pop see he moves on will it be
Hikaru Nakamura or Fabiano caruana these
are fan favorites everyone will be one
of watching that matchup
Benjamin any final thoughts before we
head on out and send it to the next
match
no this wasn't insane this was an
absolute Thriller Robert I it had
everything it had everything and uh yeah
I could not have wished for a more
exciting match
and Jana pomsi he was happy to be in the
field but he says I'm not going out
without a fight he makes his way to the
next one and while we are still here we
want to give a shout out to a new
partner with helping us with the speed
Chess Championship let's take a moment
to thank ag1 ag1 is your daily support
of key Health functions from mental
performance to energy and the immune
system it's the one product that does
the work of many to find out more visit
drinkag1.com chess or use the command
ag1 in chat thank you to ag1 for
sponsoring the SCC so on behalf of
myself and Grandmaster Benjamin Buck we
have to go but we do not say goodbye
because Hikaru Nakamura versus Fabiano
caruana is up next do not go anywhere
the next match continues in just a few
thanks for watching everybody this is
the speechless Championship presented by
coinbase keep enjoying all the great
matches here at chess
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]